Nice!
Ok, aha, Lautstärke stimmt wieder nicht, exellent oder auch nicht.
Teams, Teams, Teams, immer dieses Rumgestelle an meinen Audio-Settings, das geht mir echt
hardcore auf den Sack, aber Teams geht gar gar nicht anders, du kannst Teams nicht davon
abringendes zu machen, du kannst auch eine Browser nicht davon abringendes zu machen,
was total bescheuert ist, soll alle meine Audio-Settings in Ruhe lassen.
So, jetzt, alles klar.
Ja, ja, tatsächlich, ähm, ich hab, ähm, irgendwie ist, Moment, hab ich das, Sound stimmt
immer noch nicht so richtig, Sack, Sack, Leute, Sack, ich habe den Eindruck, dass mein Sound
rechts weniger ist als links, hab ich doch einfach nochmal ein Ohr dreckig, keine Ahnung,
hört sich aber komisch an, hab ich mit dem anderen Kopfhörer nicht gehabt, also Scheinspul
nicht an meinem Ohr zu liegen, naja, also, alles gut, ich hab tatsächlich zur Abwechslung
sogar mal ein bisschen Fußball geguckt vorhin, ja, und das einzige, was ich zu essen da hatte,
was auch nur annähernd geografisch an Portugal drankommt, ist spanische Chorizo, erstmal
schon Wurst gegrillt, Hippofettwurst, fällt mir ein, ich könnte jetzt im Stream gleich
mal eine Ladung neue Grill-Chorizo bestellen, passte eigentlich, aber das bestell ich nicht
in China, das sag ich euch gleich, also, also, Essen bestell ich nie in China, Essen bestell
ich nur bei sinnvollen Jobs, nee, nee, gab's noch nicht, wir haben auch noch nicht drüber
gesprochen, was wir machen, wir machen auf jeden Fall den zweiten Teil, wie sieht dein
momentaner PC aus, ist es im Prinzip immer noch mehr oder weniger der gleiche, wie, Moment,
ich hab hier nochmal irgendwo ein Bild zusammen, ich mach mal kurz die Mario Kart Musik ein
bisschen leiser, ja, das reicht, das ist im Prinzip immer noch der gleiche, den ich auf
YouTube gezeigt hab, mit dem einzigen Unterschied, ja, genau, also was hatte ich denn hier drinnen,
also ich hab dann 8700K, ein ultra fetten Lüfter, im Prinzip ist es immer noch exakt
genau der gleiche Rechner, einziger Unterschied, dass es 32G RAM sind mittlerweile anstatt 16G,
man muss sich mal vorstellen, man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, es
ist bald, das ist für mich immer noch unbegreiflich, ist absolut unbegreiflich, wir haben bald
Oktober, ja, also ich runde jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen auf, Juli, August, September,
okay ich sag mal wir haben bald Oktober, vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber bald Oktober
und im Oktober ist der Rechner 4 Jahre alt, das passt in mein Boomer Gehirn überhaupt
nicht rein, dass man einen Rechner in 4 Jahre verwenden kann und der gehört immer noch
zu den schnellsten, ja da ist noch eine Festplatte drin, da ist noch ne, ah ne die hab ich jetzt
nicht gemountet, da ist noch ne 2TB SSD zusätzlich noch mit drinne, da sieht man aber hier bloß
die eine Partition von und noch ne, ich glaub 8TB Festplatte, aber es geht echt nicht in
mein Boomer Gehirn rein, wie es sein kann, dass ein Rechner fast 4 Jahre alt ist und
der immer noch zu den schnellen, eigentlich oberen der schnellen Rechner gehört, das
kann doch nicht sein, the fuck, zu Zeiten als so Spiele wie Far Cry 1 rausgekommen sind,
da hast du ein Rechner wenn der eineinhalb Jahre alt war, du konntest dir die Mülltonne
schmeißen oder Crysis, Crysis konntest du auf dem Top aktuellen Power High End Rechner
richtig spielen als es rausgekommen ist, ist doch gut, ja gut ob das gut ist oder schlecht
ist, da kann man sicher nicht lange drüber diskutieren, das ist auf jeden Fall für mich
ungewohnt, hast du schonmal ne Wasserkühlung verbaut, ne will ich auch nicht, bin ich überhaupt
nicht scharf, ich weiß das ist mittlerweile easier, einfacher, gibt es das Wort easier,
ist als früher, aber wozu, ich mein ich hab jetzt so einen fetten Lüfter hier, ich hab
den da drauf, musst du mal angucken der Lüfter, der ist halb so groß wie das Gehäuse, bring
es genau das gleiche Problem hatte ich auch an der Stelle, warum lädst du dieses, warum
lädt er jetzt das Bild runter, ich will einfach das Bild aufmachen alter, so, mach mal das
Bild auf hier, komm on, falscher Mimetype gesetzt am Bild 100 pro Kacknoobs bei Guru3D,
was auch immer Guru3D ist, also hier, das gleiche Problem hatte ich bei mir auch und
man siehts hier, das fällt auf dem Bild aber kaum auf, diesen RAM Slot, den können die
nicht belegen, weil es dann kollidiert mit dem Lüfter, zumindest bei der Sorte RAM wahrscheinlich
ja und genau das gleiche Problem hatte ich auch, weil ich hab, ich war ja so bescheuert,
ich hab, ich hab mir RGB RAM gekauft, ich weiß bis heute nicht warum ich RGB RAM hab,
ich hab mir nämlich ein Gehäuse gekauft, na doch ich weiß warum ich ein Gehäuse, ich weiß
warum ich RGB RAM gekauft hab, ich weiß warum ich RGB RAM gekauft hab, weil ich ein Gehäuse
hab mit, äh, Glass, so ungefähr sieht mein RAM aus ja, Trident's RGB RAM, ähm, ah ne
das ist gar kein Gehäuse, das ist G, G-Skill, ok, ich hab, ich hab ein Gehäuse, glaub ein
R5 oder so ist das oder ein R6 oder was auch immer, mit Fenster, so und das lustige ist,
das sieht eigentlich sogar ganz cool aus mit der Grafikkarte, mit RGB, mit, also hier das
Gehäuse hat ein Fenster an der Stelle und mit dem RAM mit RGB, das, das dumme ist nur
ich hab direkt meinen alten Rechner daneben stehen und der steht neben dem Fenster, das
heißt ich kann, ich hab mir das jetzt einmal angeguckt, wie schön das RGB im Rechner ist
und dann hab ich ihn zugepackt und nie wieder reingeguckt, naja, so und da hab ich auch
das Problem, kann es sein, dass du erkältet bist, nö, ich mein vielleicht ein bisschen,
weil ich den ganzen Tag die Klimaanlage an hab, aber ich, also ich bin nicht erkältet,
das liegt wahrscheinlich schlicht in der Graf an der trockenen Luft, ja ich merke
das auch ein bisschen an der Nase, ja aber ich bin ich, bin ich krank, ne, Klimaanlage
ist halt auf Dauer auch nicht so der Wahnsinn, so und klingt es bisschen, kling ich doch
immer, aber ja gut, es kann doch nicht in der Klimaanlage sein, ja stimmt schon, hast
recht, jetzt merke ich es auch, zumindest der Ram passt nicht so richtig ohne die Lüfter,
aber ich hab Glück, der hier ist anscheinend noch ein bisschen höher, ich hab Glück, ich
konnte das so anordnen, dass ich den hier und hier hin mach und irgendwie hab ich da
noch hingekriegt hier noch einen rein zu kriegen, also ich hab jetzt 32G insgesamt
drinne, ja, egal, hat er mit dem was ich heute machen will eigentlich gar nichts zu tun,
ich dachte immer feuchtere Luft wäre schwerer auszuhalten, es ist sowohl, es ist sowohl
hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit, gerade bei hohen Temperaturen, das ist halt so viel, oder auch niedrige Luftfeuchtigkeit
ist beides kacke, also am besten, am besten ist normale Luftfeuchtigkeit und normale Temperaturen,
was ich, also was ich theoretisch machen müsste ist, ich hab hier, ich hab hier ja so eine
Klimaanlage von Mitsubishi Heavy, Z, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, bin mir nicht ganz
sicher ob das die ist, aber ich zeig euch mal ein Bild, so, genau, genauso, genau, ich
hab so ein Ding außen, außen im, sieht nicht ganz so aus, sieht nicht ganz, also ähnlich,
hängt draußen an der Wand und hier hab ich im Schlafzimmer und hier im Arbeitszimmer
hab ich so ein Ding hängen, so und was ich jetzt eigentlich noch machen müsste ist folgendes,
ich müsste mir noch so einen, so einen Luftbefeuchter, was kostet denn sowas eigentlich, ich hab
gar keine Ahnung davon, was kostet denn so ein Luftbefeuchter, Luftbefeuchter, eigentlich
müsste ich mir noch einen Luftbefeuchter holen und es wieder ausgleichen, bringt das
Ding die Luft dann per Wlan ins Zimmer, Paintschampel, Luftbefeuchter sind von ganz billig bis ewig,
ja wahrscheinlich machen die auch alle das gleich oder, was natürlich cool wäre, was
richtig nice wäre, das müssen wir jetzt mal gucken, ob es das gibt, gibt es einen Luftbefeuchter,
den man flashen kann mit Custom Firmware, das sowas, Moment, Moment, Moment, GitHub,
aha, aha, aha, wieso, was, was ne Frage, was ne Frage, wieso, alter, was, was ist das
für ne Frage, muss man wirklich fragen, wieso, ja, ok, was ist das, Moment, es gibt, die
Dinger am Wlan, seh ich das richtig, Philips Air Purifier Custom, ist, ist Air Purifier
und Humidification, Humidify, ist das das gleiche, we are all sitting in one boat, also
jetzt nochmal ne sinnvolle, ne sinnvolle Begründung, warum Custom Firmware, Custom Firmware weil
sich in der Regel einfacher integrieren lässt, Custom Firmware weil du eine kleine Cloud Anbindung
brauchst, Custom Firmware weil du wahrscheinlich mehr Funktionen einstellen kannst als der
Hersteller vorgesehen hat und Custom Firma damit die ganzen Sachen nicht irgendwie wie
die LG, wie der LG Trockner, der täglich einen Gigabyte Traffic Up und Down produziert,
also ich brauch ehrlich gesagt mein Luftbefeuchter nicht, dass der Bitcoins meint oder so, hat
der grad nen Wlan hier, Nanocloud, hat das was mit IoT zu tun oder was ist Nanocloud,
Wi-Fi, ich brauch, ich brauch nen Luftbefeuchter mit Wlan neul, das ist ganz wichtig jetzt,
der Chat hat mich auf die Idee gebracht, das sieht aus wie ein Staubsauger Roboter, wir
können mal gucken, wir können mal bei Ali, komm wir gucken bei AliExpress, machen wir
mal ne VM an, wir gucken mal bei AliExpress und schauen mal was ShowMe oder sowas so am
Start hat, das ist noch Windows 11 Alter hör mal auf, geh mal weg, ich geh mal kurz
auf AliExpress und guck mal was die für Humidifier haben, du willst Nino Kuni spielen, das ist
ein gutes Game, der erste zumindest, ich wollt noch irgendeine Frage beantworten die ich
grade vorhin gesehen hab, ich muss mal kurz durchgucken, übrigens wir haben jetzt zwei
animierte Emotes, habt ihr schon gesehen, wir haben zwei animierte Emotes, guck mal, wir
haben Whoop Pet und wir haben Whoop Hack, ja das Chatplugin kann die animierten Emotes
noch nicht ja, äh ich hab die Subs übrigens übersehen, Moment kann sein das ein bisschen
mehr reingekommen ist, ich schau mal schnell, so hat das jetzt gestartet, AliExpress, also
Juicy1337 hat wieder abonniert, Dankeschön für den Sub, Baladi ist auch wieder am Start,
endlich kann ich wieder am Start sein, Konni letztes Mal nicht am Start sein, aber nice
dass du wieder da bist, huge, Lol, schreibt Juicy, der Juicer und der Misha hat auch Subscribed,
Dankeschön, huge, so was haben die als Airhumidifier, Days Code, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub,
Leute ich hab gesehen letztens wieder, man muss mehr Sellout im Stream machen, ich muss
alle, mindestens alle Stunde einmal sagen, Leute guckt bei mir mal auf YouTube, ich kann
das aber nicht, ich kann kein Sellout so auf Knopfschluck machen, das ist Übungssache,
das ist einfach Übungssache, man muss das glaube ich noch oft genug üben, da muss man
mehr Sellout machen, weil das bringt was, man muss immer sagen, also ich hab so ein Video
geguckt, also ne, stimmt gar nicht, ich hab nur ein Video geguckt zu einem anderen Thema,
das hab ich jetzt übertragen, übertragen auf YouTube und Twitch Subscriber und Follower,
also was man machen muss ist folgendes, Big Brain Theorie jetzt, was man machen muss ist
folgendes und das mach ich lustigerweise auf YouTube unbewusst schon jetzt ne Weile, man
muss folgendes sagen, man muss sagen, man muss sich irgendwie ne gute Überleitung überlegen
so nach dem Motto ja blablabla, jetzt ist ne gute Zeit zu followen, zu subscriben auf
Twitter, auf YouTube, auf Twitch, was auch immer und dann muss man sagen, nachdem man
quasi einmal den Sellout gemacht hat für neue Subscriber und dann muss man noch darauf
sagen so nach dem Motto und ich begrüße auch wieder alle Leute, die schon lange zuschauen,
super, dass sie wieder da sind und so, das muss man machen, weil das hat zwei psychologische
Effekte hab ich gelesen, das erste ist, dass man neue Leute Chebatet, dass die, dass die
jetzt abonnieren und neue Leute abonnieren auch, weil sie beim nächsten Content zu den
Leuten gehören wollen, die man quasi lobt, dass sie schon so lange abonniert haben, wisst
ihr wie ich mein, also die Leute freuen sich, dass sie abonniert haben und jetzt quasi
so gehuldigt werden und nächstes Video warten die Leute dann darauf, dass man sagt ja und
alle die schon subscribt haben, schön, dass ihr wieder da seid, das ist Massive Sixhead
psychologisch, ja, Big Brain, hab ich heute in dem Video gesehen, hatte nichts mit YouTube
zu tun, hab ich gedacht, okay das ist, das klingt aber echt sinnvoll und das jetzt lustigerweise
übertragen auf YouTube, ich mach das ja schon ne Weile, aber, also ohne jetzt da im Hinsicht
auf die Leute zu Chebaten, ich sag ja schon ein paar Videos jetzt immer so nach dem Motto,
jetzt ist ein guter Zeitpunkt zu subscriben und ich freu mich, dass, wenn ihr das schon
gemacht habt, dass ihr wieder mit damit am Start seid, das ist ja so entstanden, weil
ich das wirklich so seh und gar nicht aus Massive psychologischem Trick, aber jetzt
wo ich das Video gesehen hab, jetzt passt, passt richtig nice, Random Comment des Tages
und begrüßen, ja, ja gut, die ganzen Leute, Leute, ich weiß, das hat jetzt mit China Shopping
nichts zu tun, aber ich muss grad noch mal auf einer Sache ein bisschen rumreiten, ja,
also nicht so auf vielleicht den Schluss, schlecht in Kombination, wenn da grad irgendwie
Mutter und Kind angezeigt werden in Werbung, war vielleicht bisschen unglückliche Einblendung
jetzt hier zusammen, aber ich muss noch mal auf einer Sache rumreiten und zwar kann mir
irgendjemand die Daseinsberechtigung von Instagram und Snapchat erklären, also Twitter
versteh ich, aktuelle News, sinnloses sich gegenseitig in der eigenen Bubble gelobe und
sonst wie, okay, die Daseinsberechtigung von Twitter versteh ich, die Daseinsberechtigung
von Facebook, die versteh ich auch, die Daseinsberechtigung von Facebook ist, dass Boomer Leute, die noch
älter sind als ich, also sagen wir mal so mein Alter und Leute, die noch älter sind,
sich dumme Boomerwitze schreiben können und so, WhatsApp ist auch klar, warum es das gibt,
das ist weil für nicht technikaffine Leute, weil die Instant Messages schreiben können,
ohne dass sie sich eine extra Nummer merken müssen, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
wo WhatsApp relativ neu war, dann haben die ganzen Noobs immer gesagt, oh kennst du schon,
kennst du schon WhatsApp, kennst du schon WhatsApp, da kannst du kostenlos SMS schreiben und ich
dachte mir immer so, Leute, das sind keine SMS, das sind ganz normale Instant Messages
übers Internet, ja, das hat mich immer so richtig geschmerzt, wenn die Leute gesagt
haben, kostenlos SMS schreiben über WhatsApp, so, dann kann ich die Daseinsberechtigung
auch verstehen, Daseinsberechtigung, ups, ich bin gerade übers Kabel gefahren, ups, so,
Daseinsberechtigung von Snapchat, kann ich auch verstehen, Snapchat hat die Leute hardcore
gebadet, also Snapchat war ja so quasi in der vorletzten Generation, die Generation zwischen
mir und den noch jüngeren war die Generation, die so mit Snapchat richtig angefangen hat,
weil sie sich Dickpicks und Tittenpicks und sonst was schicken konnten und die weniger
technikaffinen Leute dann gedacht haben, Snapchat löscht die wieder, so, das ist die Daseinsberechtigung
von Snapchat, verstehe ich auch, so, da gab es zwischendurch noch Tumblr, Tumblr hat
Yahoo, hat Tumblr komplett in Grund und Boden gewirtschaftet, ich habe gar keine Ahnung,
wem der Kram jetzt gehört, so, da bleibt jetzt nur noch TikTok, TikTok, TikTok verstehe
ich auch, Florian Dankeschön für 19 Monate Subscription hier, huge, mega Hyper Subscription,
TikTok verstehe ich auch die Daseinsberechtigung, ja, das ist für die ganz jungen Hyper, für
die ganz jungen Hyper nervöse 50 Sekunden Aufmerksamkeit spannende Generationen und
TikTok ist auch irgendwie noch lustig, also vieles von den TikTok Videos ist einfach belangloser,
lustiger Kram, kann ich auch noch verstehen, ich kann es auch noch verstehen, das einzige
was ich nicht verstehe ist, was ist die Daseinsberechtigung von Instagram, also ich habe jetzt alles verstanden
und was ist die Daseinsberechtigung von Instagram, Selbstdarstellung für Zuma, gut das ist ja
jedes Social Media, Facebook für junge Leute, ok, das kann natürlich sein, dass auf Instagram
einfach die Leute hingehen, weil sie nicht auf Facebook sein wollen,
aber das Privatleben der Influencer, das könnte ich doch genauso gut auf Twitter und TikTok
haben oder, warum braucht es da Instagram für?
Also im Prinzip, wenn ich euch jetzt richtig verstehe, wollt ihr sagen, Instagram ist quasi
das Facebook für die Jüngeren, die kein Bock auf Facebook haben, ok, das verstehe ich,
übrigens falls jemand von euch heute Fußball geguckt hat, ich gucke ja selten, aber heute
habe ich ein bisschen geguckt, ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass die Werbung auf den Anzeigetafeln
im Stadion, auf dem Fußballplatz, dass die total unterschiedlich ist zu früher, da ist
heute Werbung für TikTok, für irgendwelche anderen hippen Dinger, habe ich noch nie was
von gehört und sonst noch alles, da ist wirklich keine klassische Werbung mehr, Referando Werbung,
so was war früher, früher war da keine Ahnung, Erdinger Weißbier oder sowas war da früher
drauf, das Erdinger Weißbier, ja, Prachthalle da, Holle da, sowas war da früher drauf, aber
heute ist TikTok am Start, oh weh, was habe ich nicht gesehen, Referando habe ich gesehen,
TikTok habe ich gesehen, irgendwas mit V am Anfang.
Ach ja und YouTube Stories bestehen ja gefühlt auch zu mindestens 50% aus, einfach TikTok
abgefilmt, Screen Capture, es gibt so viele Videos auf YouTube Shorts, die auch noch das
Instagram Logo drin haben, wo ich mir interessiert das kein, anscheinend nicht, ja, YouTube Shorts
meine ich ja, so ich finde die eine Frage die ich beantworten wollte irgendwie nicht
mehr, achso, genau das wollte ich beantworten, hast du Windows in der, siehst du die Leute
haben schon drauf gehalten, hast du Windows in der VM laufen, nee habe ich nicht, ich
habe es umgedreht, ich habe Windows als Host und Linux in der VM, lässt sich einfach so
besser virtualisieren als umgedreht.
So ich hoffe ich habe nichts übersehen, Subz, wer kam noch, Nils FPS ist am Start, neun
Monate, Massive Sub hier, der Flo96, gelbe Farbe im Discord, ja das ist das wichtigste
ist, ich kann dir auch, wenn du Tier 3 Subst kriegst du dunkelgelb, mir egal ich habe da
keine Schmerzen mit, kann auch den Sellout machen, achso Reddit, Reddit habe ich ja eben
noch ganz vergessen in meiner Social Media Aufzählung, Reddit ist aber die Daseinsberechtigung
relativ klar, ne, Reddit ist halt das Forum von heute mit leider sehr, sehr beschissener
App Policy, so nach dem Motto du kannst die Sachen mobil nicht mehr im Browser aufmachen
weil es sich direkt dazu nötig die App zu installieren, aber ansonsten ja, tick, tick
das Reddit haltet noch.
Okay, das hat er für Regeldiskussionen gesagt.
Ja, Hausparty kenne ich nicht, habe ich noch nie auch nur angesehen.
Ich weiß, Hausparty ist dieses, dieses, dieses, dieses, äh, Diskussions- oder, oder dieser
Voice-Chat-Ding, keine Ahnung.
Kennst du dich mit Firewalls aus?
Geht so, kommt drauf an, was du wissen willst.
Du jebaitest aber eh wieder.
Ich hatte, ich mein, du denkst vielleicht, ich merke mir das nicht, ne, aber ich merke
mir manchmal schon so grob, was die Leute fragen und bei dir habe ich schon gemerkt,
du fragst in dem einen Stream A und, und im nächsten Stream B und im übernächsten Stream
dann, dann wieder A und widersprichst dir mit B.
Also, was, das hast du doch schon mal gefragt und jetzt ist es auf einmal wieder anders.
Kennst du dich mit Firewalls aus?
Wenn ja, was hältst du von der Firma R und S, die von der BSI, das kenne ich nicht,
nein, den Hersteller kenne ich nicht.
Was, R und S, Firewall, was ist das?
Ach, das Lancom, okay, keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Firewall Shop 24, klingt äußerst vertrauenswürdig, oder wer würde nicht bei Firewall Shop 24
sein?
So, ich muss jetzt mal kurz den Chat runterscrollen, bevor wir mit, mit, nein, nein, C++ die schlechtste
Programmiersprache auf der Welt, Alter, äh, warum nutzt du Linux, eigentlich mit Firewall
nicht diese Subsetze für Windows, äh, weil ich GUI haben will, weil ich, weil ich E3
zum Beispiel haben will und, oh, und das geht damit nicht gescheit.
Warum hast du keine Timestamps im Chat an, Jo, wozu, äh, schon wieder, ist das nicht,
ist das nicht ab 1.1., du meinst, dass diese, dass diese Freigrenze von, von 20 Euro oder
so wegfällt, ne, das ist für China bestellen vollkommen egal, das wird darauf keinen Einfluss
haben, keine Ahnung, ganz ehrlich, Smart Locks ist das einzige, was ich mir nie anschaffen
werde.
Ja, also, um es jetzt nochmal zu erklären, diese, diese, ähm, diese Grenze, diese,
diese Freibetragsgrenze vom Zoll wird auf AliExpress und China Bestellung keinen Einfluss
haben, warum nicht, weil die Chinesen big brain sind und die Chinesen nicht von China
nach Deutschland verschicken, sondern von China nach Europa und von Europa nach Deutschland
und dementsprechend greift das Ganze nicht, von der Versand von Europa nach Europa ist
ja Zoll frei, so, und was die Chinesen jetzt, also es gibt drei Varianten, was die Chinesen
machen können, die Chinesen können das in den Schiff packen und das direkt an euch adressieren
und irgendwie hier her schiffen und das wird dann hier verzollt, so, das ist die allerbilligste
Variante und das machen aber nur Kacknoobs und die Chinesen sind ja nicht doof, so, das
nächste ist, was die machen können ist, die haben direkt nen Warenlager in der EU und
verschicken das von da, das heißt auch schon mal kein Problem, ist von EU nach EU, so,
aber was die Chinesen eigentlich machen ist, du bestellst bei denen irgendwas, du bestellst
dieses Netzwerkkabel und dann nimmst du hier genau die passende Versandart, nicht Standard,
ich hab keine Ahnung was Safer Shipping ist, nicht Standard, nimm am besten Priority Line
falls es sowas gibt und dann machen die das so, dann adressieren die das und schicken
das nach Spanien oder Niederlande, AliExpress ist gerne, macht das gerne über die Niederlande
oder ich hab aber auch schon gehört, dass es über Spanien geht oder von Banggood glaube
ich ist es gerne über Spanien, so zumindest die schicken das dann an die Niederlande und
was weiß ich, was die für ein Deal mit den Niederlanden haben, kein Schimmer und dann
wird es von den Niederlanden weiter geschickt an euch, das heißt von den Niederlanden zu
euch ist dann auch ohne Zoll, das heißt sie müssen dann einmal Zoll in den Niederlanden
bezahlen und ich hab keine Ahnung was AliExpress für Zollregelungen mit den Niederlanden hat,
wahrscheinlich 5 Euro im Jahr, keine Ahnung, die werden schon ordentlich was abdrücken
aber nicht so viel wie er, das heißt ihr habt absolut kein Problem, wenn ihr was aus
China bestellen werdet, es würde mich sehr wundern, wenn es sich was ändern würde, wenn
man was aus China bestellt, klappt das eigentlich auch bei Möbeln, wahrscheinlich, ich weiß
nicht ob ich China Möbel haben will, da muss man halt den teureren Versand nehmen, das kommt
drauf an, also der AliExpress Prioritil, das kostet auch alles so viel mehr nicht, ok was
ist das, oh jetzt gibt es hier Big Brain Gesetzestext, was ist Plas Belastingdienst, alles klar,
waren die, das ist jetzt irgendwas von den Niederlanden, ist das Belastingdienst, wer
ist denn der Belastingdienst, ist das sowas wie der niederländische Zoll oder, wer ist
denn Belastingdienst, ahja alles klar, ich hab keine Ahnung was das ist, also was, waren
die von außerhalb der EU in die Niederlande gelangen, müssen sie beim Zoll anmelden, nach
ausfüllen einer Zollanmeldung können sie die Waren in die EU einfüllen, ahja gut, ja
Moment, das ist wenn ich Händler bin oder, zumindest würde es mich äußerst wundern
wenn sich für uns irgendwas ändert wenn man aus China was bestellt, was auf den Es
lauten, was, es sollte eigentlich kein Unterschied zu sonst sein, außer dass ich ein bisschen
trockene Luft hier hab, also was ich dir sagen kann zu AliExpress bestellen ist folgendes,
ich hatte schon einigen Stress mit, mit Dienstleistern hier, wo ich über Paypal bestellt hab und
musste dann mit Paypal, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel das Rack was ich mir damals bestellt
hab, das ist die Tür durchgebrochen beim Versand, das hab ich bestellt über CrowdFox,
weil das da billig war, ich weiß gar nicht ob es diese Seite überhaupt noch gibt heute,
ja, also würde ich nie bestellen, echt absolut grausame Shit, zumindest kam das kaputt an
und ich hab dann gesagt Leute, gebt mir das Geld wieder oder nehmt es zurück oder was
auch immer, kaputtenes Rack kann ich nicht gebrauchen und die haben sich ewig nicht
gemeldet, da musste ich einen Paypal Käuferschutz Fall aufmachen, die haben sich immer noch
nicht gemeldet hin und her, dann musste ich bei Paypal beweisen, dass es kaputt ist und
bla bla bla, am Ende ging es dann doch noch gut aus, die haben sich am letzten Tag gemeldet
und gesagt ich soll es behalten, ich krieg Geld zurück, aber ganz ehrlich, ich hatte
mit Paypal schon öfters hin und her, gerade wenn es ums Käuferschutz geht und bei AliExpress,
aber gerade bei AliExpress ist es so, ich hatte mit denen zweimal bisher so einen Käuferschutz
Fall und das wurde immer ohne auf den Händler zu hören in meinem Sinne gelöst, ja, ich
hatte mal einen zum Beispiel, der hat gesagt, der hat es verschickt und der Tracking Code
ging die ganze Zeit nicht und dann habe ich ihn angeschrieben und gesagt hier Tracking
Code, nee genau, irgendwann habe ich eine Mail bekommen, Bestellung wäre angeblich
fertig, habe gesagt Hallo, Tracking Code geht nicht, ist nix angekommen, dann hat er gesagt
ja, wir schicken sie ihnen neu den Tracking Code, hat er mir den Tracking Code neu geschickt
und es war der gleiche Tracking Code, wie vorher ging, immer noch nicht, also richtig
dubate, dann habe ich so einen Klärungsfall bei AliExpress aufgemacht und die haben dann
gleich gesagt aha, wir werden den Shop informieren, die haben den Shop informiert und der Shop
hat mir dann noch mal die gleiche Tracking Nummer geschickt und dann hat AliExpress drauf
geschrieben einen halben Tag später, ich soll doch bitte jetzt Bescheid sagen, ob alles
in Ordnung ist und da habe ich halt, ich habe gepennt, China-Chinesen-Zeit ist halt ein
bisschen anders als bei uns, da habe ich am anderen Morgen geguckt und AliExpress hat
das geschlossen und hat mir das Geld zurück überwiesen, also komplett umgedreht, Paypal,
da musste ich die ganze Zeit nachrennen und AliExpress hat einfach gesagt, ok, Kunde
hat sich nicht gemeldet, dass er zufrieden ist, easy Geld zurück.
Gut, wahrscheinlich haben sie jetzt dafür drei chinesische Arbeiter erschossen oder
so, man weiß ja nie, was da so läuft, so nach dem Motto, du hast uns 250 Euro gekostet
hier, hau ab, keine Ahnung, was bei den Chinesen läuft, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass
es alles eh so krass subventioniert, dass es die auch nicht großartig juckt.
Warst du gestern bei der Online-Maker-Verarbeit? Nein. Warum gibt es hier eigentlich kein Weirdchamp?
Weil Weirdchamp überall entfernt wurde. Wir hatten Weirdchamp drin, aber Weirdchamp wurde
entfernt, weil die sich gedacht haben, ne, den Typ wollen wir nicht zeigen. Weil das
Gesicht hinter Weirdchamp, also der Typ hier, weil der auf, glaub, Twitter irgendwelche
US-politischen Sachen gepostet hat, ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung was und das
hat Twitter, das hat Twitch nicht gefallen, dann hat Twitch den entfernt und daraufhin
hat BetterTwitchTV und FFZ gesagt, sie entfernen das auch.
7-TV kann ich nicht nehmen, auf 7-TV gibt es beispielsweise Bilder von Hitler und sowas
und ich hab keinen Bock, dass wenn ich 7-TV aktiviere, dann irgendwelche komischen Emotes
kommen. Also die sind nicht richtig auf Zack, was Freigeben von Emotes angeht.
Wahrscheinlich ab ersten, ich mach demnächst noch mal einen Test-Stream, mit ordentlich
Sellout dabei und ab ersten starten wir wahrscheinlich mit Hetzner Sellout, ne. Weil ich hab keine
Ahnung, ob das Corona-Leugner war, aber hab ich euch eigentlich erzählt, Leute, hab ich
euch erzählt, dass ich jetzt auch Klimaleugner bin? Ich bin seit der letzten E3 Klimaleugner,
also ich bin der Meinung, dass der Klimawandel direkt mit der heißen Luft von der E3 zusammenhängt
und nicht etwa irgendwie mit CO2-Ausstoß. Also so viel unsinniges, leeres Gelaber wie
auf der diesjährigen E3, hab ich sonst auch nirgendswo gesehen, Alter.
Könnte stimmen, ja, denk ich auch schon. Ist der Speed-Champ eigentlich fertig? Nein.
Was kommt eigentlich, wenn man jetzt auf Speed-Champ geht? Timeout, hoffentlich, ja.
So, mal Battlefield 4, hatte ich tatsächlich mal wieder vor, weil das jetzt kostenlos
ist. Und ganz gute Vorbereitung auf Battlefield 6, 2042. E3 kurz zusammenreißen ist jetzt
nicht wahr. Was hältst du von Wo'nix? Du hast immer Fragen. Ah, das ist das. Okay,
das konnte ich grad nicht zuhören. Ich glaub, davon hab ich zumindest schon mal was gehört.
Ich halte davon gar nix, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert. Die einzigen Privacy Linux Distributionen,
die ich schon benutzt hab, ist Tails und fuck. Das andere, ganz bekannte, jetzt steh ich
auf dem Schlauch. Total bekannt, bin jetzt total hängen geblieben. Wie heißt das denn?
Kali, Kali Linux, genau, Kali Linux. Das bekannteste in der Richtung, keine Ahnung, warum ich
jetzt nicht draufgekommen bin. Mit Kali Linux haben wir bei uns auf der Arbeit mal für Verwirrung
gesorgt. Wir haben uns Kali Linux in der VM installiert und mussten dann halt Updates
runterladen oder Pakete, Pakete muss man glaube ich runterladen, Pakete runterladen. Und das
haben wir halt über den Proxy gemacht. Und irgendwann, irgendwann kam einer vom Security
Team übelst, übelst panisch bei uns ins Büro gerannt. Wer lädt hier Hacker Tools runter?
Wer lädt Hacker Tools runter? Haben wir gesagt, hä? Wir haben eine Kali Linux VM, wir haben
da grad was installiert. Der, der hat den Squid Traffic, da haben die irgendein Analysetool
auf dem, auf dem Squid Traffic gemeint, Leute, die laden hier was, was ich Metasploit oder
irgendwie sonst was runter. Dann mussten wir ihm alles sagen, nee, es ist nichts Schlimmes,
wir haben eine Kali Linux VM, macht ihr keine Sorgen. Die haben, die haben voll Panik geschoben
direkt. Oh, was ist hier los? Hacker Tools, Hacker Tools. So. Und sind wir stehen geblieben.
Ich wollte einen Luft Humi, Humidifier. Humidifier Wifi. Welche, welche Wifi Humidifier? Okay,
wir suchen einfach, nach welchen die von Homo System unterstützt werden. Aha. Xiaomi ist
wieder am Start. Oh, der, der, der, der Xiaomi Smart Anti-Bacterial Humidifier, der ist sogar
anti-anti-bakteriell. Haben sie da die verbliebenen FFP2-Masten reingeklebt oder wie? Ich meine,
die China-Chinesen haben ja genug. Okay, sowas ist nicht teuer. Und das, das, das hat, hat,
der hat WLAN? Er hat auch kein WLAN, oder? Das ist, das ist in der Tat eine gute Frage.
Ja, was willst du denn sonst machen? Ich meine, ich merke es im Hals, ich merke es in der
Nase, dass die Luft zu trocken ist. Kannst du eine gute Klimaeinlage empfehlen? Ja, kann
ich, habe ich ja gerade gezeigt. Ich habe eine Mitsubishi Heavy Z. Ich kann ja leider nicht
genau sagen, welche, aber so ein Gerät hier in der Richtung ist das. Mit einem außen
und zwei innen. Sieht fast genauso aus, als wenn die Dinger kommen innen, das Ding kommt
irgendwo außen innen. Ist, ist echt top, ja. Macht auch richtig kalt. Ich habe letztens
mal Just For Fun abends im, also bevor ich ins Bett bin, habe ich die Klimaeinlage im
Schlafzimmer auf 18 Grad gestellt und volle Pulle gemacht. Also du kannst, du hast ja
da zig Einstellungen an der Fernbedienung. Und es gibt so, es gibt so einen Ultra, Ultra
Freeze Modus. Da, da bläst das Ding einfach eine Viertelstunde Maximum am Anschlag. Und
da bin ich dann da reingegangen. Ey, ohne Scheiß, das war mega kalt. Ich weiß nicht,
ob es 18 Grad waren, aber kann gut hinkommen. Gut, das ist, das ist teuer. Da kommt, das
ist sogar noch ein bisschen teurer. Also, ich, so 2000 Euro wirst du wahrscheinlich
schon, schon, ähm, bezahlen müssen, weil du brauchst ja noch Einbau und so kommt ja
noch dabei. Also ich habe jetzt hier mit Klimaeinlage, ich habe die Klimaeinlage jetzt hier auf
24 Grad stehen und, äh, ich kann die tatsächlich noch eins hoch machen. Ich habe die jetzt
hier auf 24 Grad stehen und auf Auto Lüftung und kleinsten Modus, also sprich, also, also,
nicht auf Seil-Modus, auf dem normalen Modus, aber auch nicht auf Power-Modus und jetzt
habe ich hier drinnen genau 23 Grad und das ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen kühl.
Jetzt habe ich die Klimaeinlage auf 25 Grad gestellt und, äh, so 24 Grad hier im Büro
ist top. So, also die Dinger kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Das kostet zwar ein bisschen mehr, aber mit, ich glaube, ich habe mit Einbau auch so um
die 2000 Euro ge-, ach so mobile Klimaeinlage, ne, da kann ich nichts zu sagen. Ich habe
absichtlich keine mobile Klimaeinlage für so ein, für so ein, für so ein, mit Schlauch
aus dem Fenster und sonst wollte ich nicht. Ich habe gedacht, wenn ich jetzt schon in
einem Haus wohne, wo ich auch mal was dran bauen darf, ne, also in der, in der Wohnung,
wo ich vorher gewohnt habe, ging, in der Mietwohnung ging das ja nicht, genau. Und, äh, jetzt
hier im Haus vom Opa, kann ich das endlich machen oder habe ich mir, komm, ich baue
es gleich was Gescheites an. So, hat, hat, das Ding hat WLAN? Wirklich?
Glaub ich gar nicht. Okay, Humidifier Integration. Was sind dann, was sind dann High, High-Gross-Death-Devices?
Klimaeinlage ist ein Geckenschanger, ja. Cross-Stats. Feuchtigkeit, ah. Gerät zur
Aufrechterhaltung der Luftfeuchtigkeit. Okay, das ist quasi. Okay, welche, welche Geräte
werden denn da unterstützt? Home Assistant. Hm. Wie heißen die? Mio. Okay. Mio. Mio.
Mio. Wie steuert man das an? Was, was kostet sowas denn? Ach, das ist, das ist so einer.
Äh, heißen die anders? Ja gut, äh, was das Ding an Leistung braucht,
hält davon ab, was du einstellst, ne. Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar, wenn du, wenn es wärmt. Die
Dinger können ja nicht nur kühlen, die Dinger können ja auch heizen. Das reicht schon,
wenn ich das über WLAN an und aus machen kann. Das reicht schon, da kann ich das nämlich
einfach morgens automatisch triggern lassen. Dann guck ich einfach, wenn es morgens 28
Grad ist oder sagen wir, wenn es über 26 Grad ist im Arbeitszimmer, dann mach ich einfach
morgens um 7, also quasi so eine halbe Stunde oder so bevor ich aufstehe, lass ich dann
automatisch triggern das Klimaanlage und Luftbefeuchtung angeht und wenn ich dann arbeiten
gehe, ist es richtig schön 24 Grad. Kauft ihr keine, ja, ok. Ich kann dir nur empfehlen,
wenn du wirklich Probleme damit hast mit Haltung und so, Homeoffice-Technik und so, eine Stunde
Sport am Tag, ich weiß, es klingt wie Planka Hohn, wenn ich das sage, ich bin jetzt ja
gerade für als Fitness-YouTuber bekannt, aber das ist das, was ich jetzt schon seit
ein paar Jahren mache, seitdem ich auch ziemlich Rückenschmerzen hatte, Kopfweh und so, einen
ganzen Tag. Eine Stunde, mittlerweile bin ich schon bei ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden
Sport am Tag, es reicht auch ohne Scheiß, es reicht auch, wenn ihr zackig einfach spazieren
geht. Also Hauptsache, mit Sport ist das nicht gemeint, ihr müsst euch voll verausgaben
und rennen. Hauptsache eineinhalb Stunden am Tag ein bisschen bewegen. Und selbst eine
halbe Stunde ist viel besser als gar nichts. Das müsst ihr also wirklich ein bisschen
bewegen, reicht, ihr habt keine Rückenschmerzen mehr, habt weniger Kopfweh, ist überhaupt
kein Problem mehr. Ich habe sogar einmal mit Strom geheizt im Winter, das habe ich euch
doch erzählt, wo das der Microcontroller in meiner Heizung abgefackelt ist. Da habe
ich mit der Klimaanlage geheizt, weil eine Woche die Heizung nicht ging im Winter. Ähm,
das Random Gerätesortiment von Xiaomi ist gar nicht so random, weil das nicht wirklich
von Xiaomi ist. Das ist quasi ein bisschen, mir fällt kein besseres Beispiel ein, ein
bisschen wie Amazon Marketplace. Unter diesem Label haben die zig verschiedene Hersteller,
von denen nicht alle alles machen. Die haben einen Hersteller für Handys, einen Hersteller
für Fernsehen, einen Hersteller für Thermostate und Smart Home Geräte. Da pappt dann letztendlich
das Xiaomi Logo drauf, aber unter der Haube sind das alles unterschiedliche Hersteller.
Ja, wie gesagt, reicht. Du kannst doch eine Stunde Pippa Please machen am Tag. Bakterien
in der Luft, okay. Kommt auf den Klogang an, aber normalerweise ist jetzt aufs Klo gehen
nicht so körperlich anstrengend, dass es als Sport durchgeht. Na gut, man muss ja nicht
unbedingt das machen, was als Minimum empfohlen wird. Deswegen, dass jede kleinste Bewegung
ist besser als gar keine, auch wenn es so eine Viertelstunde ist. Aber ich bin jetzt
bei ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden am Tag so hängen geblieben, das reicht. Ja, das mache
ich auch ab und zu. Das mache ich natürlich auch ab und zu. Aber das ist gar nicht so
sehr die Sache, dass man abnimmt, das vielleicht ein bisschen auch, aber die Bewegung macht
halt viel aus, gerade was Rückenschmerzen, Kopfweh angeht. Das stimmt, aber ich, das
ist eine gewöhnliche, das ist ohne Scheiß, das ist Gewöhnungssache. Bei mir ist jetzt
so, wenn ich morgens nicht eineinhalb Stunden mich ein bisschen bewegt habe oder halt mittags
wenn Homeoffice ist, da fehlt irgendwas. Wenn man das paar Wochen gemacht hat, gewöhnt
man sich da dran. Ja, das stimmt, da habe ich auch ein paar von. Ja klar, wenn man Haustiere
hat, kommt man nicht drum herum. Ne, ne, ne, die haben unterschiedliche Kontakte, das geht
nicht. Die haben die Schnittstelle an unterschiedlichen Stellen, der Raspberry Pi, der Raspberry 3.
Wenn es dir hilft, in Bewegung zu bleiben, mach. So, also, komm mal zurück. Haben die
Dinge WLAN? Das muss ich jetzt, ich hab's immer noch nicht gecheckt. Was? Welche? Was
ist denn das hier eigentlich für ein riesen Cookie-Ding? Hier App-Control, das brauchen
wir. Aber das ist doch wieder was anderes. Das checke ich manchmal an Home Assistant
nicht. Kategorie Humidifier. Ah, hier. Das ist ein bisschen wenig. Das ist ein bisschen
wenig, was sie an Plattformen unterstützen. Das Problem an dieser, das Problem an dieser
Integration ist, dass man, so wie es aussieht, äh, die weiterhin über die Cloud gehen und
das will ich ja nicht. Die gehen weiter über die Cloud und man kann sie nur lokal steuern,
wenn ich das soweit sehe. Das ist... Warum kann mir mal jemand sinnvollerweise eckeln?
Warum stellt nicht einfach ein Hersteller was her, was easy funktioniert mit einer App,
easy funktioniert über die Hersteller Cloud, aber was man auch für technisch Interessierte
und soviel sind das ja nicht, einfach auch lokal steuern kann? Die meisten Leute machen
das nie im Leben. Aber Shelley hat, Shelley hat sowas nicht. Wobei, Leute, warum bin ich
eigentlich so bescheuert? Warum mache ich den nicht einfach an eine Smart, also an eine Steckdose
dran, die ich Remote an- und ausschalten kann? Warum will ich mir überhaupt einen mit Wi-Fi
kaufen? Ist doch eigentlich total beknackt. Einstellen musste an den Dingern ja nix. Einstellen
musste ja hier nix großartig. So, mal gucken. Test. Test, größtes Scam-Master-Alte überhaupt.
Bakterien. Chip. Ok, Chip weiß Bescheid. Chip. Al-Plan. Oder auch nicht, eher nicht. Startler.
Was ist das für ein hässliches Teil? Und, und warum ist die Seite so dumm aufgebaut?
What the fuck? Jetzt mal ernsthaft. Wer stellt dieses Ding direkt ins Gesicht vom Baby? Warum?
Warum? Also wenn ich den Luft befeuchtere in das gleiche Zimmerstelle, ok, aber ich
würde den im Leben nicht direkt nehmen an mein Babystelle. Verdunster, Verdampfer oder
Ultraschallgerät. Ultraschall, die sind sehr wichtig für Braumäsche. Also, irgendjemand
hat gesagt Ultraschall sackt von der, von Bakterien. Bakterien, Ultraschall. Ja, ich
muss einfach Heilsteine kaufen. Genau, genau, genau, das ist es. Ok, ich werde mir, ich
werde mir jetzt, ich werde mir jetzt keinen kaufen, aber es muss doch irgendwas geben,
was man über WLAN steuern kann. Oder warte mal, GitHub. Ich guck mal auf GitHub, da gibt's
auch schon Custom-Firmware. Moment, AWS Cloud? Warum gibt es, warum, warum gibt es einen
Luftbefeuchtender über AWS Cloud? Achso. Ich glaub, ich glaub das Ding heißt nur Humidifier
und hat überhaupt nichts mit einem Luftbefeuchter zu tun. Ich glaub, das ist der Witz, weil
es für die Cloud ist und er die Cloud befeuchtet. Cloud-Free Humidification. Alles klar. Ok,
also anscheinend muss man sich so ein Show-Me-Ding kaufen, die einzigen, die ordentlich unterstützt
werden. Ja, interessant, muss ich mir mal anschauen, muss ich mir mal anschauen. Warum, meine, alter,
wie viel haben die denn? Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Du kannst diesen Verdampfer
empfehlen. Hat der, kann man den, wie verhält das? Das ist ein Wasserkocher, ja. Sowas hab
ich auch schon. Ok, das find ich ganz nice, das muss ich mir jetzt mal, muss ich mir mal
näher angucken. Was ist das? Humidifier. Cloud-Free Wifi, ok, das ist wieder was anderes.
Ne, doch. Siehste, Custom-Firmware, ich sag's doch, Leute. Custom-Firmware, endlich. Custom-Firmware
für den Humidifier. Beste, beste, dass sowas wieder gibt, jawoll. Was ist, was ist hier
der Unterschied? Ja, Custom-Firmware, beste. Wie flasht man das? Best. Immer, immer, immer
Custom-Firmware. Hab ich, hab ich, hab ich, hab ich. Ja, nice. Ok, das werde ich jetzt
mal ausprobieren. Ok, und für welchen, und für welchen funktioniert das? Für, steht
da, steht da irgendwo für welchen, welchen Luftbefeuchter der hat? Hier. Den da. Das
ist Luft, Luft, Luftbefeuchter. Das ist Luftbefeuchter, Custom-Firmware für Luftbefeuchter. Wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich ist es der hier. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist es der hier. So, was sagt
der Amazon dazu? 69 Euro. Hat schlechte Bewertung. Warum? Weil Attention. Oh, der Wasser, Wasser
auslaufen ist ziemlich kacke. Kompatibilität mit der deutschen App ist mir vollkommen egal,
wenn ich Custom-Firmware mache. Ja, das ist nice, ich mache Custom-Firmware easy. Direkt
Custom-Firmware. Und wie flasht man das? Ganz normal einfach, ja easy. Einfach, einfach
anschließen und gut ist. Moment, das ist das falsche, was ich hier hab. Das brauch ich.
Okay. Okay, das ist anscheinend einfach, man, er hätte mal ein paar Bilder machen können,
wie man das flasht. Ich gehe mal davon aus, man muss aufmachen und sich an die Pins löten.
Machst du das im Stream? Ja, wahrscheinlich mach ich das im Stream. Hat er weiter unten?
Ah, hier. Wo ist der, wo ist der ESP? Sieht jemand den ESP? Ich weiß, ich könnte ein
Bild runter gucken, wahrscheinlich hier nebendrauf. Wo ist der? Ach, das Teil. Ach, hier ist er,
dann ist es doch das hier an die Seite gesteckt, oder? Oder das da? Das da? Zumindest wisst
ihr was das richtig Gute an dem Modul ist, du kommst einfach an alle Pins easy dran,
das ist doch nice, dann kann man das so easy flashen. Ja, das ist doch mal wenigstens was,
da kommt man wenigstens dran. Das da? Das war von der Fab her nicht, aber von hinten
kann es schon sein. Ja, vom Anschluss her passt das. Ist ja auch egal. Das ist wenigstens
mal easy zu löten und dann wieder rein. Das probiere ich aus, Leute. Das bestellen wir
schon mal. Einfach, weil es geht. Einfach, weil es geht. Bäm. Gibt es da unten drunter
noch? Damage Filter. Bäm. Wann ist Lieferung? Montag. Ach so, Moment, heute ist Samstag,
ja kein Wunder, dass es Montag ist. Stimmt, der Preis ist eigentlich zu teuer. Moment,
Moment, wir wollen ja heute in China bestellen. Wir wollen ja heute in China bestellen, also.
Bacterial Humidifier. Das ist das ist der gleiche. Silberionen, alles klar. Das ist
der gleiche. Amazon. Das ist nicht der gleiche. Das ist ja auch ein Mii und das ist ein, wobei
das ist. Die haben oftmals die unterschiedlichen Versionen von dem Kram. Das daneben war der
richtige. Das hier, ja. Das ist, das ist wahrscheinlich. Ja, ja. Okay. Okay, wir haben
die Auswahl aus China und gecommodet. China. Stecker Typ EU. 34 Euro. Guck mal, da sieht
man es mal wieder. Der Kram kostet einfach die Hälfte aus China. Der kostet einfach
die Hälfte aus Russland, kostet 40 Euro. Der kostet einfach. Was ist denn? Was ist
da mit den Chinesen los? Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Lull. Der da. Wie viele haben die eigentlich
davon? Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf. Wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt auch gleich
schon mal bei Banggood, Alter Banggood. Ich finde immer noch. Warum denkt ihr, dass ich
das auf Französisch haben will? Nein, nein. Ah. Vergörs, Alter. Wo stelle ich denn die
Frage um? Englisch, please. Ja. Okay, ähm. Sag mal, wo, wo, wo, bin ich jetzt total
verwirrt? Wo ist die Suche hin? Hab ich jetzt gemacht? Da unten. Ach, da, die sieht man
einfach nicht. Hänge ich das vielleicht mal auf Englisch, die Seite, please? Okay. Das
geht doch nicht nur mit Sprache auswählen, das konnte das doch direkt auf Englisch. Okay,
wir müssen, wir müssen das glaube ich gerade mal austricksen. Denkt immer noch, ich komme
aus Frankreich. Meine Güte, okay. Anti Humidifier. Okay, genau, genau, genau. Okay, ich lass
mal dieses antibakterielle weg und einfach nur Humidifier. Ach, jetzt ist es auf Englisch,
genau, perfekt. Nein. Ah, gut. Humidifier. Diese, diese China Seiten sind teilweise richtig,
warte, sind teilweise richtig schlecht und vor allem AliExpress, Banggood, DHgate und
was, die sehen alle so gleich aus, als hat, wie gesagt, ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
es gibt irgendwie so ein chinesisches, äh, China, chinesisches Webdesign, Webdesign Ministerium,
das macht alle China Shops. So, also, welche ist es denn? Der da. 100. 109. Das sind die
noch, sind, was ist mit den Chinesen los? Warum sind die so teuer auf einmal? Jetzt kommt es
gleich über Amazon. Die Chinesen sind ja mega teuer. Warum ist das bei Amazon und warum
ist das bei Amazon? Guckt ihr das mal an hier? Das, das, das kann ja nicht jetzt teuer ernst
sein. Ha, da. Ha, ne, ich weiß nicht. Ne, ne, ne, das war dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen
teuer. Okay, keine Ahnung. Das, was, wo sagt hier einer was? Inflation? Nicht so schnell.
Ja, auf Dollar, aber das macht es jetzt. So ein großer Unterschied macht es. Hallo? Ja.
Germany. Was ist mit der Seite los, please? Achso, das ist UK, UK-Banggood. Ne, da bin
ich überhaupt nicht hin. Was bin ich mit UK-Banggood? Ship to Germany USD. Ne, mach, mach mal, mach
mal Euro. Euro, wo ist es da? Ja, jetzt trotzdem. What the fuck? Das ist, das ist mega, mega
teuer. Doch, doch, das macht schon einen Unterschied. Also normalerweise hat es immer einen Unterschied
gemacht. Warum ist das China Zeug so teuer? Wir haben bei Aliexpress. Jetzt komme ich aber
jebaited vor. Wo kommt man denn da hin, wenn ich nicht mehr für den Hälfte, für den
Hälfte des Preises in China bestellen kann? Guck mal, das olle Zeug kostet wenigstens
nur 33 Euro. Ne, ne, ne. Guck mal, hier gibt es den für drei, aber das ist, das ist immer
noch teuer, Alter. 26 Euro Versand? Okay, Moment. Ich muss jetzt mal nach was gucken,
was ich da schon öfters bestellt habe. Hier, irgendwelche, irgendwelche billigen Boards.
So, was kosten da... Okay, da kostete der Versand 89 Cent. Mit Kai... Kai... Kai...
Super Economy Global. DHL20. Das ist ja in Ordnung. Kann man sich 10 Boards kaufen,
aber ich bezahle auch keine 20 Euro teilweise da Versand oder 45 Euro Versand. Da kann ich
ich den Mist auch bei Amazon kaufen, sehr gut, nee, nee, nee, der Versand ist normalerweise
nicht zu teuer, ihr habt es ja gerade gesehen, 89 Cent, Suche mit EU Warenlager, äh bringt
es ja im Prinzip auch nichts, auch nicht, weil ich habe mir alle Angebote schon angeguckt,
die es gibt und die sind ja auch so schon zu teuer, also keine Ahnung was mit den Chinesen
los ist, gehst du fort, dazu, also das, nee, so geht es nicht, wo kommen wir denn dahin,
wenn der China Kram so zu teuer ist wie bei Amazon, warum ist das bei Amazon die italienische
Version, ich glaube das ist ein typischer Blödsinn was die Chinesen in den Titel geschrieben
haben, dieser Titel dieser China Produkte ist immer so ein bisschen, die wissen nicht
so genau was sie da reinschrieben, mit italienischer Version meinen die wahrscheinlich EU Version,
Italien hat andere Stecker, ok das sagt,
hat Italien wirklich andere Stecker, würde mich jetzt wundern, nö, haben sie überhaupt
nicht, was zum,
was zum, ja die Dinger kenne ich, das ist, das hier ist typischer, typischer China Stecker,
ok kein Schimmer, egal, egal, egal, glaube ich nicht, glaube ich nicht, ja passt schon,
also das werde ich auf jeden Fall mal ausprobieren hier, das probieren wir in einem der nächsten
Streams aus, einer der nächsten Streams wird dann der chinesische China Luftbefeuchter
geflasht, und ich hoffe wir machen ihn nicht kaputt, sehr gut, so machen wir das, passt,
Poggers, gekommen und regelt, so weiter, so jetzt muss ich mal bei den eigentlichen Sachen
gucken, die ich heute bestelle, was ist das eigentlich für bescheuerte Musikempfehlung,
wer hört denn sowas, wer ist denn, wer ist denn, ich kenne die alle nicht, doch von der
habe ich schon mal was gehört, wer ist, warum, was will Amazon von mir, ich, nö, ich hab
nicht einen von, ich weiß ja nicht mal wer das hier ist, wer ist Griff, Griff kann man
irgendwie festhalten, besonders gut, warum ist, warum ist die Griff, Alter, auf hessisch
würde man sagen Henkel, Kit, Guddi, ich nicht, nein, also von der habe ich schon mal was
gehört, keine Ahnung wer Griff ist, wer Hör ist und wer Kit Guddi ist, kein absolut legit
keinen blassen Chimmer, Amazon bitte am Start, also gucke ich mal in meine Liste, also das
erste was ich brauche, was ich mal gucken wollte ist, ob es gescheite, ob es irgendwelche
ordentlichen Raspberry Pi Zero, sowas da zum Beispiel, genau sowas brauche ich, weil, kann
ich euch auch erklären wozu ich das brauche und zwar, ich habe aktuell im Keller an meiner,
an meiner Heizung eine Raspberry Pi und das habe ich euch ja schon oft gezeigt, hier mein
Heizungs Dashboard, das kennt ihr ja schon, seht ihr das Problem von meinem Heizungs
Dashboard, fällt euch da irgendwas auffälliges auf, alles gut, ja, richtig, hat eigentlich
überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass ich euch das zeige, Chat blickt wieder eh nicht durch,
natürlich mir ist klar, dass das wieder natürlich der typische Twitch Chat Gebate ist, aber
man sieht daran, dass irgendwas mit den Sensoren nicht stimmt, also ja es ist Sommer, das stimmt,
aber dass der Brenner gar keine Aktivität hat, das ergibt keinen Sinn, weil warm Wasser
muss auch warm Wasser gemacht werden, so und dass hier permanent Fehler steht, obwohl die
funktioniert ergibt auch keinen Sinn, das Problem ist, ich glaube, dass entweder mein
Raspberry Pi einen Schlag hat, das glaube ich aber weniger, weil der an sich noch geht,
ich kann mich da per SSH drauf einloggen und das funktioniert noch, ich glaube eher, dass
das Kabel für die Heizung kaputt ist, das werde ich morgen mal ausprobieren, ich werde
da mal ein bisschen dran rumwackeln und gucken, eigentlich kann das auch nicht verrutschen,
aber ich wollte bei der Gelegenheit mal gucken, erstens was so ein neues Kabel kostet für
die Heizung und ein ordentliches Raspberry Pi Gehäuse, weil in meinem Keller sind, glaube
ich, da ich jetzt Mist erzähle, ich glaube 93% Luftfeuchtigkeit, also da ist ziemlich
schwitzig unten und ich weiß nicht, wie gut der Raspberry Pi das auf Dauer verkraftet,
wenn er in 93% Luftfeuchtigkeit hängt, startet dann Pi mal noch, meistens habe ich das schon
gemacht, also neu starten ist ja das erste, was gemacht wird bei sowas, so und was ist
das, das sieht irgendwie aus, als hätte es einer bei sich in Heimarbeit aus irgendeiner
Dreh, ne, das ist nicht so, sieht ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen billig aus, so und
hier ist halt das Problem, dass du komplett, der Raspberry Pi hängt im Endeffekt quasi
so direkt im Keller mit das Gehäuse, da macht nichts, so und was man bei dem Gehäuse machen
könnte ist, ich könnte das einfach zu pappen, also bei dem Gehäuse das einzige was noch
offen wäre, ist, was ist denn das da hinten, das da vorne ist USB, ah das ist HDMI, ne,
das war nochmal bei Raspberry Pi, wo, das ist ein HDMI und das vorne ist ein USB, genau,
also das einzige was ich machen müsste ist im Endeffekt hier ein zweites USB Kabel reinstecken
und den HDMI, den HDMI Port zu kleben, das wärs, also das Gehäuse halbwegs zu zu kriegen
ist glaube ich, Moment, das hat ein Loch oben, ich will den Deckel ohne Loch, ich muss nicht
an die Pins, die haben wirklich, gibt es das nur mit Loch, ach es gibt zwei Deckel, ok
dann bin ich ja beruhigt, aber das ist auch so billiger Plastik Clips, das ist dann auch
wieder nicht richtig dicht, schon Windows 11 getestet ja im letzten Stream, knall den
in eine dichte Tupperdose, ja das könnte man machen, aktuell hab ich einen Plastikbeutel,
aber das klappt nicht so gut, ich könnte, ich könnte tatsächlich den an dem ePort einfach,
einfach heißklebern drum herum, da fällt mir schon was ein, ganz ehrlich, da fällt mir
schon was ein, wobei, ich könnte das eigentlich machen wie bei meinem Kamera Raspberry Pi
Zero, ich hab ja für den Hof eine Kamera, eine Raspberry Pi Cam und die hab ich einfach
in den Schlauch gesteckt, den Schlauch hab ich dann zu heißklebert und das liegt jetzt
schon seit eineinhalb Jahren draußen auf der Fensterbank im Hof bei Wind und Regen und
es passiert dem Raspberry Pi einfach gar nichts da drin, ich glaub dann brauch ich
das Gehäuse doch nicht, ich glaub das ist ziemlich useless dann, dann hol ich mir lieber
das neue Album von Grip, der Name ist so geil, Grip, warum Grip, ja das stimmt schon, auf
der anderen Seite der Raspberry Pi eigentlich brauch ich das auch gar nicht, weil der Raspberry
Pi ist wahrscheinlich eh nicht kaputt, ich denke mal das liegt eher am Kabel und das
Problem ist, so ein Wiesmann Optolink Kabel ist mittlerweile brutal im Preis gestiegen,
wollen die mich veräppeln, 75 Euro für ein USB Kabel, was ist mit so eins hab ich, genau
so eins hab ich unten an meiner Heizung, also die Heizung hat vorne so einen Anschluss,
ich zeig euch das mal für alle die ich noch nicht hier gezeigt hab, die Heizung hat vorne
so einen Anschluss, genau hier sieht mans, hier, die Heizung hat vorne so einen Anschluss
und da steckt man das rein, das heißt es verrutscht eigentlich auch gar nichts, aber 74 Euro,
im Endeffekt ist das ein USB Kabel und im Prinzip ist das ein Serial Adapter, da drin
gehe ich mal von aus und zwei Infrarot LEDs, oder umgedreht, eine Infrarot LED und ein
Infrarot Empfänger, also zwei Infrarot LEDs, ein Serial zu USB Konverter und ein USB Kabel,
das ist in Elektronikteilen kostet das Ding 1,50, also ist die Frage jetzt viel eher was
ist kaputt, ist vorne in der Elektronik was kaputt oder ist das Kabel kaputt, ich kann
mir beides nicht vorstellen, Garantieanspruch, welchen Garantieanspruch, das was ich damit
mache, das Auslesen von der Heizung, das hat, das ist inoffizielle Sache, das juckt wies
man überhaupt nicht, außerdem ist die Heizung von 2013, ich müsste das wahrscheinlich mal
raus machen und irgendwie mal ausprobieren was da ist, aber das Zeug ist brutal teuer,
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, vielleicht kann man da selbst eins bauen, das Problem
ist nur, das ist mir eigentlich zu aufwendig, also es ist nicht wirklich aufwendig, du brauchst
keine Ahnung, paar Widerstände, zwei Infrarot LEDs und ein Board zum Trau, also es ist nicht
so schwierig, ich hab mir das auf, ich kann euch mal die Bauanleitung zeigen, so kompliziert
ist das nicht zu bauen, man könnte das dann, wenn man hier Bauanleitung, USB, Moment gibt
es da schon, gibt es da schon ein fertiges Board für, Keg-Wade, wo hat der das Board
her, da PCB-Way oder wo hat er das Board her, kannst du die Daten manuell über den
Raspberry Pi auslesen, ne, wie gesagt irgendwas mit dem Kabel ist nicht in Ordnung, wo hat
er denn, wo hat er denn die, wo hat er denn das Board her, hat er denn Link, Max wird
heute noch gezockt, was denn, achso, neue Varianten kosten 21 Euro, ok das ist schon
mal deutlich billiger als das Optolink, ich dachte der hat vielleicht einen Link zu PCB-Way
oder wo man das Board direkt bestellen kann, was Byteslink.de wer ist das, warum komme
ich da auf Google wieder raus, das bestimmt, das bestimmt, Proxy Gebate, Google Proxy
die bei sich auf dem Web-Server laufen, ja klar, du kannst das natürlich, du kannst
das gleiche an die GPIOs vom Raspberry Pi dranhängen, klar, das kannst du machen, aber das funktioniert,
ich meine, ob du jetzt einen Serial auf USB Adapter hast und das USB am Raspberry Pi
anschließt oder das Serielle direkt am Raspberry Pi, klar, das funktioniert, aber ich kann
es gerade nicht, also ich kann nicht vom Raspberry Pi das Ding auslesen, ohne die Zwischensoftware,
doch, also das ist Schallplan, ok, zeig mal her, ich glaube das ist nicht allzu schwer,
USB, also das scheint mir überschaubar zu sein, aber ich habe kein Bock das selbst zu basteln,
dann bestelle ich das lieber für 21 Euro bei dem Dude, aber ich werde, bevor ich was
kaufe Leute, bevor ich was kaufe, ich meine, guckt euch das mal an Alter, 76 Euro für
so ein komisches USB Kabel, ich werde morgen einfach mal am Kabel wackeln, ja, hast du
die Logs geprüft, ne, ich habe heute auch nicht lange geguckt, ich habe heute Mittag
reingeschaut und habe festgestellt, hier, irgendwas ist im Arsch, ich habe keine Ahnung,
es kann auch sein, dass es funktioniert, wenn ich den Raspberry Pi einfach mal ausstecke,
wieder einstecke oder das Kabel mal ein und ausstecke, kann sein, ich wollte jetzt bloß
mal gucken, ob es das nicht schon billiger irgendwie gibt, aber ganz im Ernst, 76 Euro
für ein USB Kabel, da baue ich es im Zweifelsfall sogar, hier, guck mal, sogar 86 Euro, sind
ja alle nicht mehr ganz bei Trost, was DHL Paket beim Zoll, Chat, Chat, manchmal verwirrt
mich der Chat, entweder ist es komplett zusammenhanglos oder ich habe keine Ahnung, um was ich es beziehe,
ja, ne, eigentlich habe ich auch keinen Bock, den Kram selbst zu löten, ich würde gerne,
dann gäbe ich dem Typ lieber 20 Euro, vielleicht ist es auch nicht kaputt, ich muss mir das
mal morgen oder am Montag angucken in Ruhe, aber 74 Euro plus Versand, ihr seid, die sind
noch echt nicht mehr, die sind noch nicht mal ganz bei Trost, Alter, was ist das für
einen Preis, ne, gehste weg, dazu kann ich nur eindeutig sagen, weg, so, also, das Optolink
und das Pi Case hake ich mal ab, so, was ich da noch brauche, und das kriegen wir bestimmt
schön billig, schön billig in China, wobei das Ding ist auch in Deutschland jetzt hier
nicht, sondern nicht teuer, brauche noch Luftfeuchtigkeit, Temperatur, Sensor, so ein 5er Pack, hatte ich
das letzte Mal schon geguckt, aber hatte ich nicht bestellt, ich habe keine mehr, ich habe
bloß noch die ganz billigen, ich habe nur noch die ganz billigen, ich habe nur noch
DHT11 und DHT22, glaube ich, da und die Sacken, die hier sind viel besser, ähm, warum, warum
kostet das hier bloß 2, 2, das kommt bestimmt aus China direkt, das kommt, wartet ab, das
kommt direkt aus China, ja, ja, ja, das kommt wahrscheinlich direkt, direkt von den Chinesen
kommt das, hat man nicht, hatte man hier nicht den Knopf für Only Prime, gab es nicht jemanden
Knopf für Only Prime, wo ist der hin, dass das nur wenn ich eingeloggt bin, kommt das
nicht alles von Chinesen, doch, aber die Frage ist, ob es von China, ob es aus China direkt
verschickt wird, oder ob das hier über Amazon geht, wenn es hier über Amazon geht ist es
schneller da, aber direkt aus China ist es halt billiger, hier, Eats, Eats Delivery,
bei denen habe ich schon öfters bestellt, aber da kostet es halt gleich mal, da kostet
es gleich mal 5 Stück 8,50 Euro und wenn ich das auf AliExpress bestelle, kostet es wahrscheinlich
einfach nur 2 Euro, übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subs, ich gucke mal schnell rein,
Matt3F oder MattiF ist es wahrscheinlich, oder Mathe, MatheF, 9 Monate, danke für den
Sub, huge massive IQ++ Subscription, Sphynication hat Subscribed vor 17 Minuten, Dankeschön
und der Nils ist auch wieder am Start vor einer Stunde, habe ich gar nicht gesehen hier,
huge massive Subscriptions, dazu kann ich nur sagen, weeps in, so was kostet der Kram
hier, AliExpress 7,98, alter was ist mit den Chinesen los, what the fuck, sind das wenigstens
20 Stück oder so, wie viele sind denn das, das kann doch nicht nur 1 sein, warum hat
das 3,3 Volt Modul mehr Anschlüsse als das 5 Volt Modul, es verwirrt mich hoch gerade,
das hier ist ein 10er Pack, zeig her, ich muss mir erstmal den Link angucken, nicht dass
jebaited wäre, ja passt, viel, viel, was, hä, ich bin äußerst verwirrt, ich hab die
gleichen Module bei mir schon da und die haben nur 4 Anschlüsse, die haben, die haben
die Module, ich hab solche Module hier, genau, genau, die Module haben 3,3 Volt, Ground und
hier irgendwie 2 Bus Anschlüsse, Nilsiu, Dankeschön für den Sub, oh das ist eine
gute Frage, kann ich kurz was zu sagen, hast du eine Firma angemeldet für das YouTube
Twitch Money, genau, das hab ich gemacht, ja und ich hab einen Steuerberater seitdem
ich den YouTube Kram mache, weil ich da selbst nicht durchblicke und ich absolut keinen Bock
hab mich damit zu beschäftigen, da bin ich noch gespannt drauf, weil die Chinesen machen
es ja in der Regel so, dass sie erst in die Niederlande schicken und dann von den Niederlanden
nach Deutschland und dann von EU nach EU gibt es kein Zoll, das wäre für mich auch mal
eine Premiere, das jetzt mal auszuprobieren, also ich bin so ein Modul, das ist auf jeden
Fall eine bessere Variante, was ist denn das, warum hat denn das hier, warum hat denn das
andere Modul so viele Anschlüsse, was sind denn das für Anschlüsse überhaupt, zeig
mal her, hat das eine Beschriftung, vielleicht so, ah hier, das hat plus minus, STL, STL und
was ist das, was ist CSB und STL, hat das, hat das vielleicht I2C und das andere alles
in einem oder, für was sind denn die Anschlüsse, die hier verstehe ich, aber wofür sind die
zwei, das sind irgendwelche Steuerungsdinger, die man wahrscheinlich gar nicht brauche,
da kann man, da kann man verschiedene Protokolle drüber machen oder so, das ist kein Druck,
das ist Luftfeuchtigkeit, Temperatur und Drucksensor in einem, Druck, Temperatur, Luftdrucksensor,
Moment, das sollte, ja Temperatur, Luftdruck, Luftfeuchtigkeit, alles in einem, ich glaube,
der hat beide Protokolle, also stammarmäßig kann ich es wahrscheinlich einfach hier dran
anschließen und gut ist, das ist tatsächlich relativ einfach, das Problem ist, ich würde,
ich würde mich dazu sogar mal in einem Video äußern, das ist bei mir allerdings jetzt
schon sieben Jahre her, ich weiß das eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig, was ich damals gemacht
habe, ich weiß und ich musste zu irgendeinem Amt, ich musste zu einem Amt ein Formular
holen, dann musste ich das ausfüllen, das war ein ganz, ganz merkwürdiges Formular,
da stand da so was drauf, wie sind sie Seemann oder im Forstwirtschaft oder so was und das
waren irgendwie 14 Seiten und da habe ich gesagt, Alter, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich hier
ausfüllen soll, dann bin ich zu meinem Steuerberater, habe den gefragt, was muss ich denn da machen
und der meinte so, ach ist alles unsinnig und hat irgendwie alles durchgestrichen, meinte
hier, tragen sie das da ein und ich musste von den 14 Seiten quasi zwei Seiten ausfüllen
und dann war das Ding angemeldet, nachdem ich es da abgegeben habe, aber da stehen ganz
komische Dinger drauf, so Förster oder Seemann, ne, ne, ne, ne, da steht, die fragen nicht,
ob du Seemann bist, da steht dann irgendwie so was drauf, wie sind sie länger als vier
Wochen im Jahr auf See und so was, fuck.
Genau, im Endeffekt sind es nur zwei Seiten, aber dieser gesamte Antrag war irgendwie 14
Seiten oder so lang, wie gesagt, ob ich Seemann bin oder ob ich Förster bin oder, keine Ahnung
mehr, es war ganz, ganz, wie auf jeden Fall, okay, ich nehme aber auf jeden Fall lieber
die Variante, es ist auf jeden Fall, es ist auf jeden Fall schon deutlich billiger als
bei Amazon, wobei so viel billiger ist, das bei Amazon gar nicht, gucke mal, gucke mal,
das ist, das ist, das ist bei Amazon gar nicht so viel billiger, wenn sie bei Eats, Eats
Delivery gucken, da kostet das, ah Moment, das ist hahaha, das ist einer, fünf, okay,
es ist ein bisschen teurer als bei Amazon, aber warum geht das so, das irritiert mich
richtig, warum ist das China Zeug in letzter Zeit so teuer, ja, was ist denn mit den China,
das klingt garantiert an Corona, das wird auch wieder billiger, der Kram, der Kram war
mega billig die ganze Zeit, aber jetzt ist es teurer geworden, das ist sieben, sieben
Euro, wäre das ein Zehnerpack oder so, okay, zolltechnisch ändert sich ja nichts am Preis,
sondern höchstens, höchstens, vielleicht lassen sie das im Versand irgendwie mit reinhauen
oder so, zehn Stück, 70 Euro, sind die, sind die von allen guten Geistern verlassen die
Chinesen jetzt oder was, what the fuck, da kann ich es mir auch direkt vergoldet bestellen
bei Konraten auf der Zeil abholen gehen oder so, alter ich habe keine Ahnung was mit den
Chinesen los ist, ich bin sprachlos, dass das so teuer ist, man das ist okay, das ist
in Ordnung, 74 Cent, ja, 74 Cent passt, kommt halt erst am zweiten August, Standard Chipping,
ja, ich meine das passt jetzt wenigstens halbwegs, jetzt hast du hier zehn Stück, sagst du Einkaufs,
Hallo AliExpress, please, Einkaufswagen, so, jetzt hast du zehn Stück, oh jetzt habe ich
zwanzig drinne, ups, zehn, wie Null, warum Null, achso man muss ankreuzen, ne doch, das
ist trotzdem, ich meine es ist billiger als bei Amazon, da kosten drei Stück schon fünf
Euro noch was, aber trotzdem, ne denn es ist ja, das lohnt sich jetzt ja wegen Corona überhaupt
nicht mehr in China zu bestellen, er wollte mir ernsthaft erzählen, ich soll in Zukunft
normale Preise für Elektronikzeug bezahlen oder was, das so geht es aber nicht, Paynes
Champ, USD bestellen, ja das macht doch jetzt auch keinen so großen Unterschied, warst du
vielleicht ein bisschen was, aber es ist eigentlich so teuer, das ärgert mich, das ärgert mich,
dass der China Kram so teuer ist, na gut, dann lasse ich das jetzt erstmal und überlege
mal was anderes, wir sind noch nicht fertig, wir sind noch nicht fertig, was kosten zum
Beispiel, jetzt gucken wir mal was, also eine Sache von der ich weiß, dass die immer saumäßig
billig waren, sind so diese Teile, diese billigen Bewegungssensoren, die sacken aber auch richtig,
die sind auch teurer geworden, was findest du, wie findest du Windows 11, ich meine ich
erkenne ehrlich gesagt die Neuigkeiten an Windows 11 nicht, ich hab's mir angeguckt,
das einzige was mir aufgefallen ist, ist dass das Startmenü in der Mitte ist und jetzt
irgendwie so sieht aus wie Gnome 3, aber ansonsten ist es genau der gleiche, Mist im Endeffekt
wie Windows 10, du hast immer noch die alten Windows XP Control Panels und so dabei, die
Dinger sind auch teurer geworden, davon hab ich aber noch ein paar, die muss ich nicht
bestellen.
So was konntest du dir mega billig sonst in China kaufen, wobei 70 Cent sind glaube
ich relativ normal.
Guck mal, ich meine du kriegst den gleichen Krempel 5 Stück für 8,99 schon bei Amazon,
so und hier, zeig mal her, 5, gut hier kostet die Hälfte, aber da kommt nochmal 2 Euro
Versand drauf, das ist gar nicht, das ist jetzt nicht so der riesen Unterschied, den
ich normalerweise da erwarten würde, ich mein guck mal bei AliExpress bezahle ich dann
irgendwie 6 Euro und hier bezahle ich 8,99, das ist natürlich okay, weil es halt billiger
ist, aber früher hast du bei AliExpress, wenn hier 5,9 Euro kosten, hast du früher
bei AliExpress 2,50 dafür bezahlt.
Ne, also was ist mit den Chinesen los, wollen die ernsthaft jetzt ordentlich bezahlt werden
für ihre Arbeit, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, sowas, das sollte verboten werden
Alter, was ist denn hier los, wo kriege ich denn meine billigen Elektro Teile jetzt her,
wenn die alle ordentlich bezahlen werden wollen für ihr Geld, können wir nicht einfach
noch ein paar Container dabei stellen mit 5 Chinesen mehr drinne, dass das Elektronikzeug
wieder billiger wird, so war es aber auch, die haben es doch sonst mit Menschenrechte
auch nicht so, einfach noch 5 neue Fabriken hin, hauptsache billig für mich, ja das wird
das eigentliche Problem sein, ich hätte ehrlich gesagt übrigens auch gar keine Schmerzen
gehabt, das muss man heutzutage immer dazu sagen, dass die Leute, wenn man Witz macht,
mag einer nicht witzig finden, aber nicht den falschen Hals bekommen, ich hätte damit
überhaupt keine Probleme, aber dann würde ich halt nichts in China bestellen, der einzige
Anreiz für mich in China zu bestellen, man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, dass das umwelttechnisch
jetzt auch sicherlich nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist, wenn da jeder Privatsanzeug dann
mit dem Schiff hier her schicken lässt, der einzige Anreiz für mich bei AliExpress zu
bestellen ist eben, weil es weniger als die Hälfte gekostet hat bisher, und gerade wenn
man dort ein 20er Pack oder so bestellt, dann hat sich das halt wirklich auch bemerkbar
gemacht, ja gut dann wird dann nichts, übrigens was kosten eigentlich bei Ikea so einen ZigPee
backen, ah das gibt es bei AliExpress, sowas da, 16€, soll ich es aber achten, soll ich
es aber achten, ja hier, bei Amazon kostet das Ding so viel, bei Ikea kostet es 10€,
die Logik versteh nicht, ah ja Ikea mach, ja mehr Ikea Tracking please, weil ich hab
mir überlegt, 10€ kostet, weil ich hab mir überlegt, dass so ein paar Schalter eigentlich
relativ cool wären, um ein paar Sachen zu triggern bei mir in der Wohnung, ich hab aktuell
so einen ZigPee Schalter von Xiaomi, der ist aber von der Verarbeitung her jetzt nicht
so, ich hab hier so ein Aquara, so ein Teil, das hat zwar mehr Funktion als der Ikea Knopf,
so ein Teil hier hab ich, eBay aber so ein Schalter, der ist von den Funktionen her eigentlich
ganz cool, weil du hast 6 Knöpfe, so und das Ding kann unterscheiden, Single Press,
Double Press, Triple Press, Long Press, also das heißt, im Endeffekt kann man hier 18 verschiedene
Funktionen mit abbilden, also nee wobei, warte mal, Single Press, Doppel Press, Triple
Press, Hold, Hold hab ich noch vergessen, also sogar 4, also sogar 4, ich hab grad nur
mit 3 gerechnet, nee, du kannst 24, du kannst 24 Funktionen damit abbilden, also die Dinger
sind schon cool, aber das Problem, was ich damit hab, ist erstens, dass die Batterie
extrem, wirklich, ich kann das gar nicht, also extremst beschissen zu tauschen ist,
ich zeig euch das mal, und dass der manchmal Klicks verschluckt, Auto Change Battery, pass
mal auf, pass mal auf, Pains Champ, Pains Champ, richtiger Pains Champ, guck mal wie
man hier die Batterie tauscht von dem Ding, also ich hab so, ich hab Licht, ich hab die
aktuelle Funktion so, links oben hab ich Licht an und aus, Deckenlicht an und aus in
meinem Arbeitszimmer, und rechts oben hab ich Arbeitszimmer, Boomer muss schlafen Modus,
wenn ich den drücke, dann geht die Heizung auf die Temperatur runter, die sie machen
soll, das Deckenlicht geht aus, das, falls ich vergessen hab, Serverraumlicht geht aus,
das Elgato Keylight geht aus, also im Prinzip, im Prinzip könnte ich sogar Rechner runterfahren
damit machen.
Wie schnell benachrichtigt Pains Champ, wenn was zu UVP verfügbar ist, der Pains Champ
benachrichtigt dich sofort, du musst halt den Browser laufen lassen, das ist über
Home Assistant, genau, also ich hab hier Licht an und aus, und hier Boomer muss ins Bettmodus
oben rechts, aber pass mal auf, wie beschissen sich die Batterie tauschen lässt, ihr müsst
den nicht hören, ihr müsst den nicht hören, ich laber eh drüber, so hier hat er sein
komisches E-Fix-It-Fummel-Tool, wie auch immer das heißt, hast du zum Beispiel Studio 2000,
nee hab ich noch nicht, gibt's da jetzt eine Beta, gibt's da jetzt eine Beta von, das gucken
wir uns einem der nächsten Streams an, ich schreib mir das mal kurz auf, nicht Projekt-Ideen,
Stream-Ideen.
Der Desktop ist doch top, so guck mal, du musst irgendwie da drunter fummeln, ich meine
der Typ braucht 5 Minuten um die Batterie zu tauschen, komm mal, du brichst das übrigens
fast ab wenn du es versuchst die Batterie zu tauschen, siehst du, oh wie es jetzt anhört
schon, so und wer jetzt denkt, da ist die Batterie drunter, so einfach ist es nicht,
Monka W gibt's nicht, nee, aber wir haben Monka Giga, das ist viel besser, so Schraube
aufmachen und wer jetzt denkt, jetzt kommt man an die Batterie, nein, nein, nein, so einfach
ist es auch nicht, das ist ein batteriebetriebener Multifunktionsschalle, ja, oh wie sich, hört
ihr, hört ihr wie das knackst, ist übrigens immer noch keine Batterie zu sehen, man hätte
übrigens unten einfach eine Klappe dran machen können für die Batterie, ne, der dritte
Batterie ist kaputt, guckt euch das mal an, für das Batteriewechsel, guckt euch das mal
an, sind die Chinesen noch ganz dicht, wer hat denn das gebaut, ich hätte es auch schon
kaputt gemacht, wer hat das gebaut, seht ihr das, das ist immer noch keine Batterie,
immer noch keine Batterie, da ist die Batterie, also das ist wirklich, also das ist wirklich
der Witz, ne, also man kriegt das schon hin, ich glaube, das kriegt jeder mit genug Zeit
auch hin, aber das ist manchmal ernsthaft, ja, aber die Batterie hält wirklich lang,
du brauchst ja im Prinzip nur wirklich Batterie, wenn du drückst, also ist wahrscheinlich
die Selbstentladung das größte Problem da, das machst du dreimal auf, dann ist es abgebrochen,
das erste Mal ist wirklich am besten, du schneidest wahrscheinlich hinten ein Loch rein, ja,
das coole ist, am Boden, das ist magnetisch, also du kannst das an den Türrahmen magnetisieren,
so habe ich das auch gemacht, das ist halt echt praktisch, ne, aber was da den chinesischen
Designer geritten hat, weiß ich auch nicht, und ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich ein
chinesischer Designer war, nachdem sich der letztens einer auf Twitter darüber aufgeregt
hat, weil ich was zu einem China-Produkt geschrieben habe, das kann auch ein Brasilianer in China
gewesen sein, aber es ist ein chinesisches Produkt, es ist relativ nahe, dass es ein
chinesischer Designer war, nichts der Sorts, es ist auf jeden Fall ein chinesischer Hersteller,
und was auch immer der Designer des chinesischen Herstellers sich dabei gedacht hat, es ist
mir schleierhaft, der einzige Sache, die sie sich gedacht haben können ist, hey, die Leute,
bevor die die Batterie wechseln, kaufen die sich lieber einen neuen Schalter, und deswegen
wollte ich mir mal so einen Ikea-Schalter ausprobieren, hast du Sprachassistenten?
Ne, habe ich nicht, das einzige, was ich verwende ist ab und zu mal Siri auf dem iPhone, aber
ansonsten, und dann auch nur, wenn man keine Hand frei hat, also eigentlich nur, also das
einzig sinnvolle Siri-Anwendungszweck meiner Sicht ist, wenn du über dem Auto sitzt, aber
ansonsten verwende ich die Diktierfunktion manchmal halt noch, weil es schneller ist
als schreiben, aber das war's, ne, aber hab ich nix, hab ich nix im Einsatz, so, davon
bestelle ich mir mal ein, das sind Zigbee-Buttons, die sind einfach zu integrieren, und ich glaube,
die Dinger sind ein bisschen besser als der China-Crap, unterm Strich ist da wahrscheinlich
genauso China-Crap drinne, wie in den anderen Chinaschaltern, aber ich hoffe, dass es ein
bisschen einfacher und besser verarbeitet ist und man die Batterie wechselt, kann man
die Batterie wechseln?
Produktgröße, Bewertung, so nennt sich das also, Batterie wechseln, Eats-Klappe hinten,
Fernbedienung, Unboxing, ne, ich will es nicht unboxen, ich will einfach die Batterieklappe
sehen, falls es eine gibt, ah, hat auch, guck mal, das hat auch so ein magnetisches Ding,
kann man das auch an den Türrahmen magneten, das wäre natürlich äußerst praktisch, das
wäre das Coole an dem anderen, Batterie ist das ok, ja dann werde ich mir wahrscheinlich
sowas holen, echt ganz nice, so ich hab noch was, was ich in China suchen wollte, nämlich
16x16 LED-Matrix BS2818, mal gucken, was die jetzt gerade kosten in China, 16x16 brauche
ich, Black Siebel, 16x16, das ist auch, das ist auch teuer geworden, ich druck mich, ja
ich druck genau, ich druck ne neue Lampe, also ich hab ja schon ne Lampe gedruckt, die
ist so geil, die find ich richtig gut, ich wollt mir noch 2-3 drucken für, das ist die
beste Lampe zum selbst drucken bisher, die ich gesehen hab, also wirklich Spock, das ist
8x8 ne, 16x16, warum ist das so teuer, Alter, ok, 16x16 LED, ok ich hab nichts gesagt,
aber Amazon kostet mittlerweile 7, Alter, ajajaja, was du damit machen willst, das hier, ja
ich kann es dir zeigen, nämlich das was Stripes gerade gepostet hat, sowas, ich kann es übrigens
noch ein bisschen genauer zeigen, ich hab davon sogar ein Video gemacht, kurz ein bisschen
runter scrollen, noch nicht so lange her, jetzt die Katz erwischt, das sieht doch niedlich
aus wie sie da durchguckt oder, Chico hat übrigens ein eigenes Emote, ja, Chad hat schon
die gecheckt, so, Pepo Fett, so, wo hab ich meine Lampe gepostet, ich bin da nicht so
schnell, da, guck mal, da sieht man die Lampe im Einsatz, ja gut, warum ist Twitter Video
eigentlich so painschampig schlecht aufgelöst, Mods mal wieder schneller, ja, Poggers Mods,
sowas, das ist mein 16x16 LED Matrix, 3D gedruckte Lampe, ist echt nicees Teil, so und ich hab
jetzt hier eine, wie wäre es eigentlich mal deine Druckerplatte, das wäre keine schlechte
Idee, aber solange es noch geht, gehts, ich spiegel mich, ja ich sehe, oh nein, ich spiegel
mich im iPad, MonkaS, Leak, Wupp Leak, ist das nicht cool, das sieht jetzt ein bisschen
kacke aus mit dem iPhone, aber ist schon nice, richtig fancy Sofa, ja, wie machst du das
Webin, das ist WLED, das hab ich gar nicht gemacht, das ist ein fertiges Projekt, ah,
das ist echt cool, wobei ich hab doch auf YouTube ein Video, das sieht viel besser aus, da sieht
man das doch auch, wartet mal, es ist auch total einfach zu bauen, hier, gabs auf Thingiverse,
hier sieht man, wie es aufgebaut ist, guck mal, das ist im Prinzip einfach nur dieses
1, 1, 16x16 LED Matrix, guck mal, hier sieht man es gut, das ist die 16x16 LED Matrix,
die wird hier einfach reingeschoben, das ist eine, eine 16x16 LED Matrix, die wird hier
reingeschoben, in der Mitte hängt ein ESP866, ich glaub, das ist noch einer meiner D1 Minis
und hier unten hab ich so einen Stecker reingebohrt in den 3D Druck, fertig, also das ist wirklich
ne Sache von einer Stunde, also der Druck dauert vielleicht bisschen länger, wenn man es ordentlich
druckt, aber das Zusammenbauen ist ne Sache, wenn man es noch nicht gemacht hat, ne Sache
von einer Stunde, wenn man die Dinge hat, ist wirklich nicht schwierig, man kann das,
man könnte das übrigens noch, man könnte das tatsächlich noch ein bisschen schöner
machen, genau, man könnte gucken, dass, ja, das ist, das ist richtig, dass man ein bisschen
Abstand, Abstand hat, also dass man das entweder ein bisschen größer druckt oder halt, dass
so ein bisschen Abstand ist zwischen den LEDs und dem Rand, weil das coole daran wäre,
dass man das dann halt ein bisschen mehr diffusst, das, das Licht, übrigens das 3D, also das
ist auch nicht gedacht mit weißem Filament zu drucken, er hat das glaub ich mit irgendwas
anderem gedruckt, aber das funktioniert auch so wunderbar, ne, genau, wenn man es dann
einschaltet, das ist was, ich schalte mal runter, leichter, so, wenn man es dann, da unten ist
ein Knopf dran, so, und wenn man es dann einschaltet, dann, ok, sieht man nämlich auch, dass es
mit Spacern tatsächlich besser wäre, guckt euch das mal an, guck mal, das seht ihr,
das ist ja eigentlich schon ziemlich gut gleichmäßig, aber hier an der Stelle ist es halt ein bisschen
gebogen, das ist nicht schön, also besser, es wäre auf jeden Fall cool, man würde innen,
man würde innen was ausdrucken zum reinmachen, dass die, dass die, dass der Abstand, so quasi,
dass es halt rund bleibt, ja, also am besten wäre hier außen ein bisschen Abstand und
hier innen noch was, wo man das reinmacht, dass es eben genau rund ist, aber es sieht
wirklich für, in einer Stunde selbst gemacht absolut top aus, das Teil, und siehst du
auch von außen kaum, dass da ein bisschen mehr Abstand ist, die Intensität der LEDs
kannst du einstellen, ja klar, Lamp Champ, genau, ihr seht, dass es auch alles schön
in Home Assistant integriert, kannst du an- und ausschalten, kannst du Helligkeit dimmen
und machen, was jetzt hier irgendwie auf meinem iPad nicht richtig funktioniert, aber normalerweise
funktioniert das, ja hier guck, jetzt kannst du die Helligkeit einstellen, Polo Polo und
du kannst die ganzen WLED Effekte einstellen, ich mach jetzt gleich noch irgendeinen komischen,
ja, genau, und jetzt hab ich hier den KappaPride LED Lampe, das sieht kacke aus, aufgenommen
mit dem iPhone, aber das sieht, wenn ihr es mit den Augen seht, nicht so aus wie hier,
das ist echt nice, ich mein, es kostet nicht viel, wenn die Chinesen nicht so teuer wären
mit den LED-Panels, und es ist wirklich cool, sobald es auch noch ganz gut aussieht, und
man braucht ja nichts für, du brauchst nicht viel, du brauchst ein D1 Mini, du brauchst
die 16 x 16 LED Matrix und ein paar Kabel, so, und wenn du ganz besonders fancy bist,
dann machst du es so wie ich, dann machst du da unten ein Loch rein für den Stecker,
du kannst den Stecker aber auch, also du kannst den Stecker theoretisch auch im Boden machen
und hier unten nur was kleines rausschneiden, wenn du so einen Durchführungsstecker nicht
hast.
Flexi Play, was ist das, keine Ahnung, was das sein soll, achso, ja, wenn ich es aufmache,
das ist klar, okay, ja Lamate, das kenne ich, das Ding ist viel zu teuer, das ist irgendwie
240 Euro für so eine kack Lampe, das hier ist tatsächlich ganz nice, das ist tatsächlich
ganz cool, ja, aber genau, deswegen wollte ich mir noch ein 16 x 16 LED Matrix kaufen,
nach Möglichkeiten möglichst günstig, ja, mal gucken, was die Chinesen dafür wollen,
ach, das ist klar, 16 x 16, okay, 8 x 2 und 3, das passt, dann 8 x 8, 9 x 9 und 7, okay,
das ist immer noch deutlich billiger als Amazon, aber vielleicht gibt es das auch noch billiger,
8 x 8, 16 x 16, das ist überall das gleiche, man muss übrigens gucken, dass man es richtig
rum rein macht, sonst stimmt der Verlauf der LEDs nicht, ob es im Kreis ist, aber das kann
man WLED auch einstellen, ja, AliExpress, das ist aktuell gerade saum, also okay, saumäßig
teuer kann man nicht sagen, ist immer noch billiger als bei Amazon, aber es ist ziemlich
teuer geworden, man kann es einfach, guck mal hier, man kann es einfach nicht oft genug
sagen, die Chinesen wollen nicht mehr für umsonst arbeiten, wobei die Leute, die das
in China herstellen, sehen ja von dem Geld, nix, aber ich glaube, davon bestelle ich mir
trotzdem noch zwei Stück, Prime Day, Prime Day ist doch, ist doch, wann ist denn Prime
Day, nächste Woche, Prime Day ist eh wieder richtig krasser Chebat, am Montag, zwei Tage,
warum ist Prime Day zwei Tage, sollte Prime Day nicht eigentlich nur ein Tag sein, oder
ist das, oder ist das irgendeine Kokona Einheit, dass da ein Tag mittlerweile 48 Stunden hat,
wen juckts, wenn wir sagen, ein Tag hat zwei Tage, dann ist das so, hell yeah, okay, das
Problem am Prime Day ist, ich sag euch jetzt mal wie es ist, da ist nix dabei, da ist wieder
nur Kacke dabei, das einzige, was sich beim Prime Day lohnt ist, Amazon eigene Geräte,
also sprich, wenn ihr ein Amazon Tablet wollt, als Dashboard, oder irgendwie ums zu flashen
oder sonst wie, dann lohnt sich das, ansonsten ist da einfach nur Müll dabei, wir gucken
uns das an, Leute, wir gucken uns, ich schreibe mir das mal auf, wir gucken uns am Montag,
ich hab ja noch frei am Montag, also ich arbeite am Montag eh nicht, wir gucken uns das mal
kurz an und ich wette mit euch, es ist nicht eine Sache dabei, wo ich sag, ja, geil, wollte
ich schon immer haben, endlich günstig kaufe ich jetzt, es werden wieder einige Sachen
dabei sein, wo ich mir denke, ja, kann man sich kaufen, aber eigentlich sinnlos, wann
bewirbst du dich bei Otto, warum soll ich mich bei Otto bewerben, deutscher Ottolan,
ne, warum, was soll ich, wie kommst du auf Otto, wie kommst du jetzt auf Otto, vielleicht
gibt es ja beim Prime Day wieder eine Grafikkarte für UVP, auch wenn ich da mal eine Zweifel
hab, um ehrlich zu sein, ach stimmt, ja, warum wollte ich mich nochmal bei Otto bewerben,
stimmt, wir hatten Stellenanzeigen von Otto angeschaut und das war so schwachsinnig, ach
ja, das war die Stellenanzeige, ja, ja, ja, weiß nicht, ob ich das mache, so, eine Sache,
die ich aber auf jeden Fall wieder brauche sind Solder Joints oder wie der Kram auf Englisch
heißt, ne, wie heißen die Dinger, wie heißen die Dinger denn auf Deutsch, ich such diese
Kombination aus, Schrumpfschlauch und Löten in einem, die Lieder weide ich, genau, Waterproof
Solder Connectors, ok, alles klar, Lötverbinder, ja, genau, so versuch ich, ich hab ja letztens
in einem, wo wir letztens China geguckt haben, ich glaub ich brauch wieder welche, ich hab's
mir in der Zwischenzeit nicht gekauft, letztes Mal hatte ich den Fehler gemacht, dass ich
ein Set gekauft hab, wo leider viel zu viel große dabei waren, also nehmen wir mal das
hier als Beispiel, ich hatte so ein Set, das könnte sogar das sein, die da und die da,
ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher, welche die Kleinen sind, also ich brauch die Großen
brauch ich nicht, ich brauch nur die Kleinen und die Mittleren, alles andere ist viel zu,
genau, ich brauch nur die Weißen und die Roten, die Blauen brauch ich eigentlich so
gut wie nie, oder waren es die Gelben, ich weiß nicht, zumindest war das Set nicht so
nice, also ob du je was bestellst, na, vieles bestell ich mein, ich bestell ja nicht über
den Account hier, äh über den Browser hier, aber ich hab vieles davon bestellt, klar,
natürlich nicht alles, ah, BBQ Sauce hab ich bestellt, das letzte Mal, die Dinger hab
ich nicht bestellt, das Ding hab ich bestellt, das sieht man sogar im Video, da ich jetzt
so ein Ding an der Wand hängen hab, in diesem Surferraum Video sieht man das, Steckdose
habt ihr ja schon gesehen, hab ich genug am Start, 70 Euro für den Luftball, viel zu
teuer, viel zu teuer, würd ich ihm im Leben nicht kaufen. Hyper F, bist du derjenige auf
GitHub, der die Customfirma dafür gemacht hat? Ach ne, ne, fast, das ist Hypher, du
bist Hypher, ne, du bist, du bist das, oder? Poggers, nice, ich wollt mir das Ding bestellen,
ich wollt mir das Ding, ich wollt mir das Ding bestellen, weil ich deine Customfirma
gefunden hab. Ach du bist auch der mit der Customfirma für den Staubsauger, nice, nice,
die hab ich auch bei mir am Start, die hab ich auch bei mir am Start, wobei ich sagen
muss, ich bin, ich bin auf, auf der dunklen Seite gelandet, ich hatte, ich hab jetzt,
ich hab den Fork drauf gemacht, ja, aber das ist, ist richtig nice, also, Leute, wenn
wir grad mal da sind, wenn er grad mal da ist im Stream, ich weiß von euch haben viele
GitHub Accounts, bei der Gelegenheit könnt ihr mal bei ihm vorbeigucken, wenn das was
ist, start mal ne Runde, ja, mag jeder, wenn seine Sachen gestart werden. Genau, ich, ich
hab, das war die, das war die eigentliche Inspiration, weil ich gesagt hab, ich brauch
ne Luftbefeuchte, ähm, weil bei der Klimaanlage, okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen bescheuert,
dass man sagt, die Klimaanlage macht so trockene Luft und deswegen brauch ich Luftbefeuchte,
aber das war der, der ursprüngliche Gedanke dahinter und da hab ich gedacht, hey, gibt's
nicht ne Luftbefeuchtung mit Customfirma und das ist das erste, was ich gefunden hab,
wobei ich jetzt halt gesagt hab, ey, für 70 Euro, naja, leider gibt's es, leider gibt's
es bei den Chinesen auch nicht billiger hier. Ich hab vorhin geguckt bei AliExpress, ähm,
der Kram kostet in China sogar noch mehr mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, was da los ist, aber es lohnt
sich nicht. Lohnt's, lohnt's null. Also nee, das, das kaufe ich auf keinen Fall. Es ist
komisch, dich selbst im Stream zu sehen. Kommt mir auch immer so vor, ich, ich mach ja noch
nebenbei, nebenbei, nebenbei YouTube-Videos und manchmal, wenn's ganz abgedreht ist, gucken
wir im Stream YouTube-Videos von mir. Das ist dann richtig weirdchamp. Da, da denk ich
mir auch immer, jetzt hör ich mich selbst, wie ich zu nem Video von vor zwei Wochen rede,
dann ist es ganz vorbei. Oh, ist schon spät, ist schon spät, Leute. Ihr wisst, ihr wisst
eigentlich, was um 22 Uhr ist, ne? Boomer-Bat-Get-Time. Aber heute ist Samstag. Okay, ähm, hab ich
noch irgendwas auf meiner, auf meiner Einkaufsliste? Also die 16x16 LED-Matrix hatten wir geguckt,
das ist einfach viel zu teuer, mittlerweile auch, also ich mein, in China geht's, ne,
das ist in Ordnung, dafür, neun Euro geb ich dafür aus, aber keine 27 in Deutschland.
Oder, mal gucken, ich hab gar nicht nach Versand geguckt. Hab gar nicht nach Versand geguckt.
Hä? Wait a minute, war das nicht eben noch bei neun Euro? Warte mal, war das nicht eben
noch bei neun Euro? Ah, die hier war mal bei neun Euro. Ne, das ist acht mal acht. Ne,
16x16. WS2, genau, das sind die richtigen. So, und jetzt Versand, kostenloser Versand,
ja, das ist okay. Ja, das ist doch in Ordnung. Das kann man sich doch, guck mal, kostenloser
Versand nach Germany bis 11. Juli. Und es sind, es sind nur noch Leute, wir müssen uns
beeilen. Es sind nur noch 990.999 verfügbar. Welches Jahr, by the way? Warte mal, Juni,
Juli, Juli. Warte mal, Juli ist nächsten Monat, klar, muss ja sein, bei 11 da kann
ja nicht mehr diesen, ist ja logisch, ne? Ja, da kann man fünf Stück vom bestellen,
5 Stück und dann nehmen wir nicht Standard Shipping sondern...
Oh, please!
Warum braucht Premium Shipping länger?
Ach, ist da der neue Kundenrabatt mit...
Die chibäden doch.
Die...
Das, das stimmt.
19 Euro, das wäre ja komplett...
Daneben.
Ich hab leider kein, also ich hab keinen Bock mich hier einzuloggen jetzt im Onstream.
Mit Mail und Passwort.
Ich mein, das wär okay, das könnte man machen.
Also hier gibt's den für 59, okay, zeig mal her.
Chinesische China-Chinesen.
Was war das teuerste, was du je bei AliExpress bestellt hast?
Gute Frage.
Bäh, das sind andere.
Ne, ne sind's nicht, das sind die richtigen, alles klar.
Das sind die richtigen.
Ja, das sind die richtigen.
Ja, das ist okay.
Aber ist auch kostenloser Versand, passt doch.
Oder DHL 36 Euro, ein Schnapper, ein Schnapper.
Also lass mal überlegen, was war das teuerste, was ich jemals bei AliExpress bestellt hab?
Also die ganzen Teile, die ich bestellt habe, sind meistens nicht teuer.
Aber ich hab schon öfters größere Bestellungen gemacht.
Lass mal überlegen, was war das teuerste, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr jetzt.
Wahrscheinlich irgendeine Sammelbestellung aus Microcontroller und Kabels und irgendwelchen Kram.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Also über 100 Euro bin ich schon gekommen, das weiß ich.
Aber ich überleg grad, ob ich irgendwie mal was Großes...
Den Roborock hab ich ja nicht bei AliExpress direkt gekauft.
Den hab ich ja bei irgendeinem Amazon-Angebot damals günstig gekriegt.
So günstig, dass ich den irgendwie zwei Jahre nicht mehr so für den Preis gesehen hab.
Mittlerweile ist es billiger geworden, der S5.
Den S5 hab ich mir übrigens nur gekauft, weil es Customfilme dafür gab.
Weil ich ab echt keinen Bock auf China klaut.
Danach hatte ich diesen Bug, dass der sich ab und zu resettet hat, aber das tritt jetzt nicht mehr auf.
Also ich find das echt geil.
Wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, kann es ja mal zeigen, das ist das Webinterface von meinem Staubsauger.
Kannst du mir die Map vom Wohnzimmer angucken jetzt.
Wenn ich den jetzt starte, dann erschrecke ich ein paar Leute.
Das mach ich jetzt nicht, aber das ist wirklich richtig nice.
Das ist ein bisschen eine ältere Version, ich glaub da gibt es mittlerweile schon was neueres.
Aber es ist richtig super und ich hab mir das damals nur gekauft, weil es Customfilme für den Staubsauger gab.
Weil ich wirklich absolut keinen Bock hatte, dass es jedes Mal über die China klaut gehen muss.
Kann die Firmware alles? Was bedeutet alles?
Die kann alles, ja, easy, gar kein Problem. Alles. Alles kann die.
Obbei ich könnte jetzt ja das ganze noch ein bisschen...
Die kann alles, solange du C++ programmieren kannst.
Alles was der sonst auch kann...
Ich würde sagen zum größten Teil schon, die kann sogar mehr an manchen Stellen.
Also beispielsweise Support für mehrere Stockwerke und sowas war glaube ich da drinne, bevor das das in der offiziellen Firmware gegeben hat.
Ein Webinterface hast du in der offiziellen Firma auch nicht.
Aber es gibt sicherlich manchmal Sachen, wo halt der Hersteller es besser machen kann.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts ein, was die offizielle App kann, aber die Customfirmer nicht.
Aber letztendlich, was brauchst du großartig? Du brauchst eine Map.
Du brauchst eine Map von deiner Wohnung, du brauchst Zonen, die du drauf definieren kannst.
Und das Staubsauger muss da halt rumfahren.
Fertig, also.
Für den S6 gibt es... Du kannst die gleiche Customfirmer für den S6 verwenden.
Das Problem ist, dass du den S6 nicht so einfach... Also wir reden hier übrigens, ich zeig mal die Staubsauger.
Dass du den S6 nicht so einfach flaschen kannst.
Zumindest das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt hab, musstest du den S6 noch aufmachen.
Wir können übrigens gerade mal auf die Seite drauf gucken.
Die Customfirmer benutzt immer noch das gleiche zum Fahren.
Also so wie ich das sehe, ist die Customfirmer jetzt nicht irgendwie ein komplett reverse-ingeniertes Ding.
Sondern die haben... Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es genau gemacht haben.
Ich geh mal davon aus, die repackagen die Originalfirmer irgendwie, zumindest die Binary-Teile.
Und haben halt eine Webinterface noch dazu gebaut.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, wie es funktioniert.
Jetzt hab ich mir nicht angeguckt, aber ich vermute mal, dass da viele Teile noch von den Originalbinaries drin sind.
Weil wer soll die Steuerung für das Ding nachprogrammieren?
Wer wäre ja auch irgendwie ziemlich bescheuert.
Weil das funktioniert... Guck mal, sogar Hype meint, das ist so.
Dann wird es ja auch wohl wirklich so sein.
Dementsprechend ist halt auch das Problem, du brauchst halt ab und zu mal ein Firmware-Update, falls es irgendwelche Bugs gibt.
Zum Beispiel hatte ich am Anfang einen Bug, dass der Laser-Scanner, der da oben drauf war, also dieses Ding hier,
das hatte Probleme mit meinem Fernseher.
Und zwar immer, wenn das auf den Fernseher zugefahren ist, ist dieser Laser irgendwie komisch reflektiert vom Bildschirm.
Und dadurch ist während der Fahrt mein Wohnzimmer immer länger geworden.
Das Wohnzimmer hat am Anfang gestartet mit den passenden Dimensionen und der Staubsauger ist dann durchgefahren.
Und das Wohnzimmer wurde immer länger, immer länger, immer länger, sodass der nie fertig geworden ist.
Das war ein Bug, da muss man einfach ein Firmware-Update machen.
Jetzt ist das weg.
Also mein Staub...
Ich meine, das Ding hat es dann irgendwann gecheckt, dass es jetzt besser zur Basis fahren soll.
Aber das hast du auf der Map gesehen, das Wohnzimmer wurde immer länger.
Das heißt, du musst schon ab und zu gucken, dass du die neuere Firmware drauf machst.
Aber jetzt, ich habe schon eine Weile nicht mehr geupdatet, brauche ich auch nicht, weil es funktioniert alles wunderbar.
So, und für den S6 gibt es wie gesagt auch die Custom-Firmware, bloß dass man den so weit ich weiß aufmachen muss dafür.
Und das ist nicht so schön.
Obo-Info.
Ja.
Genau, das ist das worauf das alles läuft.
Aber die Frage ist ja, wie kriegst du die Custom-Firmware drauf?
Das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, hat man für den S6, musste man den noch aufschrauben.
Ganz abenteuerlich, da gibt es sogar ein YouTube-Video zu.
Roborock S6.
Genau, guckt euch das mal an.
Also das würde ich wirklich keinem zumuten.
Selbst wirklich technisch sehr versierten Leuten.
Du musst dieses Ding auseinanderbauen.
Anlöten, flaschen und dann, und das ist das eigentliche, ich glaube bis zu dem Zeitpunkt hätte ich damit auch keine Probleme.
Auseinanderbauen, anlöten, flaschen und so.
Alles kein Ding, kriege ich irgendwie gebacken.
Das Ding aber wieder zusammenzubauen, dass es danach noch gut funktioniert.
Da habe ich so meine Bedenken mit.
Guck, der baut es hier komplett auf.
Du musst es dann von der Batterie powern und dran.
Es ist wirklich Hardcore.
Also so extrem will ich dann doch nicht treiben bei mir.
Aber solange der S5 gut funktioniert, bleibt es auch soweit.
Und den nächsten Staubsauger-Roboter, den ich mir kaufen werde, falls der S5 mal den Geist aufgibt.
Oder falls ich mir für das Erdgeschoss noch ein extra kaufe.
Wird einer sein mit Self-Cleaning-Station.
Und da gibt es ja leider noch gar nichts für.
Oder?
Ich glaube, das ist der hier.
Ist auch wurscht.
Also da kümmere ich mich dann drum, wenn es soweit ist.
Ich finde es aber cool, dass mittlerweile immer mehr Hersteller mit Self-Cleaning...
Also im Prinzip funktioniert es ja folgendermaßen.
Du hast da einen Staubsauger-Roboter, der fährt rum.
Und dann gibt es irgendwo eine Basis-Station.
So wie der hier.
Und in die Basis-Station kommt dann einfach ein ganz normaler Staubsaugerbeutel.
Und die Basis-Station saugt den Staubsauger aus.
Richtig Gatschi-Buzz-Moment.
Miteinander gesaugt.
Also der Staubsauger saugt den Dreck in der Wohnung auf.
Und die Basis-Station saugt den Staubsauger aus.
Sehr gespannt auf den Streaming.
Von denen habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Das Google-Ding macht mich fertig, wenn es hier von der Seite so reincreept.
Bei Xiaomi habe ich mitgekriegt, dass sie das angekündigt haben.
Bei denen bin ich aber skeptisch.
Die sagen ja, dass der neue Roboter von denen die Basis-Station unterstützen wird.
Allerdings, ich weiß nicht, soweit reicht mein Vertrauen in die China-Hersteller nicht,
dass ich das denen glaube.
Dass sie sagen, wenn ihr euch das jetzt kauft, in einem Jahr kommt dann die neue Basis-Station und das passt.
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich sehe.
Von denen habe ich noch gar nichts gehört.
Aber ganz im Ernst, solange das Ding noch tut, ist das wunderbar.
Und den nächsten kaufe ich dann mit Self-Cleaning-Basis-Station.
Mal gucken, wie ich das damit mit Firmware und allem mache.
Eigentlich wollte ich noch ein bisschen mehr bestellen.
Heute war ja Fußball.
Ihr wisst, ich bin kein großer Fußball-Fan.
Aber ich habe geguckt und ich habe mir danach schön mal eine Chorizo gegrillt.
Weil das das einzige ist, was ich habe, was halbwegs nah an Portugal dran ist.
Was eigentlich spanisch ist oder mexikanisch, je nachdem welche Variante.
Aber ich habe nichts aus Portugal gehabt sonst.
Und eigentlich müsste ich mir mal mit an neue...
Ich glaube, so hieß dieser Shop.
Wie hieß dieser spanische...
Nicht in Hanau.
Shop?
Jamon.
Genau, aber den hatte ich ein paar Grill-Chorizos bestellt.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Boah, das ist aber auch teurer geworden.
Sag mal, was ist denn gerade los?
Wollt ihr mich alle arm machen oder wie?
6 Euro für eine Packung Würst inklusive Versand.
Und der Versand war auch gerade so billig.
Die Dinger sind aber wirklich ziemlich nice.
Also das ist vielleicht übertrieben, so wie das ausschaut jetzt.
Normalerweise ist Chorizo so ein bisschen getrocknet, so ein bisschen wie Salami.
Und das ist aber eins im Grill.
Was, mein Discord-Link ist RIP, echt?
Mod-Check?
Nö, mein Discord-Link funktioniert noch.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Leute, checkt mal, geht der bei euch noch?
Das ist Shibate, oder?
Der funktioniert noch.
Üh, ist hier kein Problem.
Dazu, dazu kann ich nur sagen, hier.
Ja, hab ich mich verarschen lassen wieder.
Huge Shibate.
Massive.
Bei dir steht, dass er nicht gehen würde?
Okay.
Vielleicht kann ich einen Mod auf neuen generieren, auf die Schnelle und gucken, ob der lang geht.
Keine Ahnung, aber das sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
So, äh, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben gerade?
Genau, ne.
Das ist heute die Wurst, die ich mir gegrillt hab.
Auch die in Spicy.
Aber warum ist das so teuer geworden, ey?
Zumal das glaube ich auch nur spanische, ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Marke ist, aber das ist wahrscheinlich
spanische Supermarkt, ist das.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du in Spanien sowas im Supermarkt.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich auch jetzt nicht mal irgendwie super krass Huge Quality oder so.
Zeug ist echt teuer geworden, aber schmeckt echt nice, ja.
Wie ich jetzt drauf gekommen bin, ach so, wegen Portugal.
Ja, die sind, das sind eh die besten, das sind die besten, aber die sind halt teuer.
Also wer auf italienische Sachen steht, ist auch was für die Veganer unter uns.
Übrigens diese Webseite, ne.
Oh, ich bin erst mal auf, ich bin auf UK.
Alter, lass mich, na gut, dann gehen wir halt auf UK.
Ähm, aber die hier, die wollen uns echt wissen, ne.
Die wollen uns, ey, pass mal auf, die haben hier, die haben Traubensaft.
Traubensaft, höher.
27 Euro, easy.
Alle, alle die zu viel Geld haben.
Es sind 6 Flaschen, ja, aber trotzdem.
6 Päckchen, 6 Päckchen Traubensaft.
1 Päckchen Traubensaft für 4,50.
50 Euro in China, was bekommt der Zoll dann?
Wenn es AliExpress richtig macht, dann gar nichts, weil die in die Niederlande verschicken und dann von den Niederlanden nach Deutschland.
Schmeckt aber bestimmt gut, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, also ich habe bei denen bisher nur bestellt.
Äh, Nudeln, Vollkornnudeln, also Spaghetti habe ich bestellt.
Ähm, Fusilli, wenn man das ausspringt, habe ich bestellt.
Das Dinkelnudeln-Package habe ich bestellt, da fand ich aber nicht alle so geil.
Äh, ich glaube Ricatoni hatte ich auch schon.
Also die Nudeln sind mega nice, das Öl ist auch nice, aber auch viel zu teuer.
Also, ich würde es mir wahrscheinlich verkaufen.
Äh, und dann habe ich ein paar Soßen probiert, die braucht man nicht unbedingt.
Aber die Nudeln sind wirklich geil, ich kann das nur noch mal empfehlen.
Also, wer mal wirklich richtig gute Spaghetti haben will, die man nicht, also wirklich absolut gar nicht mit Lidl Spaghetti vergleichen kann, dann die hier.
Ich meine, du bezahlst halt für ein Päckchen 2,35 Euro, ich weiß nicht, was kostet ein Lidl?
Was kostet ein Lidl Spaghetti?
Lidl Spaghetti, Kosten, Päckchen?
50 Cent, 60 Cent?
Was?
Hat er so ein Fertiggericht irgendwie?
Spaghetti, Preis.
Hier, 30 Cent.
Ne.
Doch.
Was? Moment.
500 Gramm.
Hä?
100 Gramm?
Hier.
Ah, 100, 100, ne.
Die Packung kostet 500 Gramm, 50 Cent.
Oder wie?
Okay, die Packung kostet 50 Cent, hier kriegste halt, äh.
Ah, wo hatte ich das andere denn jetzt?
Wo hatte ich das andere denn jetzt?
Hier.
Äh, hier kriegste halt 500 Gramm für 2,35.
Das kostet halt einfach fünffache.
Aber die sind wirklich gut, also kann ich echt nur empfehlen.
Wenn man wirklich richtig gute Spaghetti fuddern will, der bestellt sich hier was.
Der Nachteil, wenn ihr bei den Italienern hier bestellt ist, ihr habt Versandkosten frei erst ab 100 Euro.
Das heißt, da müsst ihr euch mit irgendjemand zusammen tun, weil ansonsten wird es noch teurer.
Und irgendwann, wenn es mir mal danach ist, bestelle ich mir den hier, bam.
Die müssen auch fünfmal besser sein, ne, sowas skaliert nicht linear.
Sowas ist, Geschmack ist eher so ne.
Würde ich sagen, eher was logarithmisches.
Ja, genau.
Also, vielleicht am Anfang noch doppelt so viel doppelt so gut, aber danach ist eher dann, das nächste Verdoppeln ist dann schon nur noch, nur noch, nur noch dreimal so gut.
Also, ne, erst mal doppelt so gut und dann dreifach so, also dann quasi nur noch ein halbes dabei, so.
Aber das ist wirklich echt, echt gut.
So und irgendwann, irgendwann habe ich mir voll genommen, kaufe ich, kaufe ich mir den hier noch, bam.
Das ist, das ist die komplette Pippo Fett Ladung.
Da habe ich wenigstens die 100 Euro Mindestbestellwert auch.
Da hast du Wurst, da hast du Käse, da hast du, frag mich nicht, du hast Öl, du hast Wein, du hast Spaghetti, du hast Soßen, du hast alles, du hast alles, bam.
Da bist du in der Woche, da bist du in der Woche abgesch, verköstest, ja.
Ne, das hält länger, das meiste hält ja eine Weile.
Ja, aber ich habe jetzt genug Werbung für die gemacht, reicht.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn ihr euch mal richtig gute Spaghetti gönnen wollt, dann holt euch die von denen.
Das hat, das kannst du echt nicht mit Lidl vergleichen, schmeckt viel, viel besser.
Schreibt die mal an wegen Sponsoring.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein italienisches Weingut jetzt so das in großes Interesse daran hat Twitch Streams zu sponsoren.
Ich glaube gar nicht, was das ist.
Wie heißt die Seite nochmal hier?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig ausgesprochen habe.
Oh, die haben einen Forum.
Ach nee, unsere Farm, unsere Farm.
Ja, die haben eine Webcam, die ist Paintschamp, die ist gerade dunkel.
Moment, ist das versuchte Nightwishen, was die da haben?
Ah ja, alles klar.
Das ist ja das Schlechteste zu meiner Gewaltzeit.
640 mal 480.
Aber man erkennt es, also ich kenne das Bild vom Tag, man erkennt es.
Hier ist halt der Hof und hier ist halt das Haus.
Das ist schon wirklich Paintschamp, richtiger Paintschamp.
Ist das oben Unix Timecode? Gute Frage, habe ich jetzt gar nicht geguckt.
Quatsch, das ist nicht Unix Timecode.
Das ist das ganze normale europäische Sommerzeit.
Die sponsoren echt Technik-Podcasts.
Ach, das da.
Das sieht nach Unix Time aus.
Ja, 16, das sieht ganz hart nach Unix Time aus.
UnixTime.de
Au, die Seite.
Ich vermute mal, dass das in Millisekunden ist.
Das ist in Millisekunden.
Ja, guck, das ist in Millisekunden.
Das hier ist in Sekunden.
Die sponsoren wirklich Technik-Podcasts? Ernsthaft?
Oh, dann lasse ich mich von den Sponsoren, Pog.
Dann machen wir es wie Dance Gaming.
Der hatte mal so einen Hot Pocket Sponsoring.
Dann hat er in jedem Stream, hat er sich einen Hot Pocket in der Mikrowelle gemacht.
Und hat die im Stream gefuttert.
Dann mache ich mir einfach im Stream ab und zu mal einen Teller Spaghetti.
Also ich mache mir nicht im Stream einen Teller Spaghetti.
Ich mache mir einen Teller Spaghetti.
Und dann mache ich einen Stream oder hole mir den im Stream.
Dann sage ich, Leute, hier, ich bin gerade am La Fiala, wie auch immer, wenn sie ausspricht, Spaghetti futtern.
Dann futter ich die Spaghetti.
Das geht schnell, Leute, bei mir.
Wisst ihr, also ich kann sehr schnell große Mengen Spaghetti verspeisen.
Nur der Friseur ist schneller.
Also ich kann schon relativ viel, relativ schnell essen.
Also ich meine, ich bin jetzt kein Competitive Eater oder sowas.
Aber der Friseur toppt das Ganze echt noch.
Also der Fabian ist wirklich hart drauf.
Dafür hat es, also ich habe den Fabian selten geschockt gesehen.
Der ist auf alles vor.
Also den Fabian kannst du selten schocken.
Aber das einzige Mal, wo ich mal wirklich gesehen habe, dass der Fabian geschockt war,
ist, als er das erste Mal in seinem Leben Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof rausgelaufen ist.
Da hat er gesagt, Alter, was hier für Leute rumlaufen.
Das ist aber auch verständlich.
Jeder ist geschockt, wenn er das erste Mal aus dem Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof läuft.
Also Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof ist erstmal Kulturschock.
Deswegen war ich in Berlin auch gar nicht so geschockt.
Wo damals dieses Battlefield 1 Event war, da sind wir ja nach Berlin,
das ist eines der sinnlosesten Events aller Zeiten gewesen, nach Berlin gefahren.
Da waren auch ein paar Leute dabei, die auch gesagt haben, Alter, was hier für Leute rumlaufen.
Ich habe mir gedacht, wieso? Ist das doch wieder heim?
Bist du in Berlin? Läufst du in Berlin?
Das erste, was ich in Berlin gesehen habe, ist, ich bin in Berlin aus dem Hauptbahnhof rausgelaufen,
erstmal an der falschen Seite.
Das ist richtig chibate, du weißt nicht, wo du raus musst am Berliner Hauptbahnhof.
Und da bin ich erstmal aus der falschen Seite raus, da war falsch,
da bin ich durchgelaufen zum anderen Ausgang.
Und das erste, was ich hatte, da darf man noch Penner sagen,
weiß nicht, ob das politisch inkorrekt ist mittlerweile, hat mich direkt mal angehustet.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ist ja wieder heim in Frankfurt
und habe mir nichts weiter dabei gedacht.
Also ich war null geschockt vom Berliner Hauptbahnhof.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof immer gewohnt war.
Du wurdest von einer Frau angebettelt oder angebellt.
Das kann in Frankfurt beides passieren.
Also, dass man am Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof angebettelt wird, kommt oft vor,
dass man angebellt wird.
Hatte ich jetzt noch nicht, halte ich aber auch für nicht ausgeschlossen.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof lässt die Leute angebellt werden.
Also wenn ich mir die Leute angucke, die da rum...
Wir hatten mal einen, der hat gedacht, der ist ein Flieger.
Der war geil.
Der ist da lang gerannt, hat die Arme ausgebreitet
und ist da so lang gerannt, hat gemacht...
Der hat Flieger gespielt und ist die ganze...
Also der Typ, der war, das war kein Kind, das war ein Drogenabhängiger.
Der ist da rumgelaufen, hat Flieger gespielt
und ist dann im Kreis geflogen im Hauptbahnhof.
Oh, nicht im Hauptbahnhof, am Hauptbahnhof, so im Kreis geflogen.
Da hast du schon fertige Leute in Frankfurt, ohne Scheiß.
Ohne Spaß, Leute hier.
Da hast du schon wirklich...
Die Krone der Schöpfung.
Wie triffst du da?
Max, drop mal deines Signature Haftbefehl...
Du meinst, Goethe-Straße Louis Vuitton Store
zahlt die Kollektion barfick auf Sponsor.
Meinst du die?
Das ist die einzige Haftbefehl.
Die einzige Haftbefehl, Textstelle, die ich kenne.
Ich höre weder Deutschrap noch Haftbefehl.
Das einzige, was ich kann, ist das.
Stimmt, ich muss Sellout machen.
Leute, wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat,
ich gehe jetzt pennen gleich.
Könnt ihr mir euren Prime-Sub dalassen?
Ich kann kein Sellout.
Ich kriege es einfach spontan nicht hin.
Ich muss da wirklich mehr üben.
Das muss man anders machen.
Das muss man ganz anders angehen.
Könnt ihr mir euren Prime-Sub dalassen?
Das ist komplett falsch.
Ich muss erst mal sagen,
Leute, schön, dass so viele Leute wieder dabei sind.
Dass so viele alte Gesichter wieder aufgetaucht sind.
Richtig nice das Stream gewesen.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon mitgekriegt habt.
Aber wenn ihr euren Amazon-Account mit Twitch verknüpft,
da könnt ihr einmal im Monat einen Streamer eurer Wahl
kostenlos mit einem Prime-Sub unterstützen.
So in der Richtung muss man das machen.
Also, übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subs.
Vielleicht ist ein schlechter Sellout
sogar besser als guter Sellout.
Man sieht, dass das funktioniert.
Torz, danke schön für den Sub.
Dumbboy ist auch am Start.
Die Abo-Falle, jetzt kommst du eh nicht mehr raus.
Kralm ist am Start, Prime-Sub, danke schön.
Wer ist dieses Self-Hosted Asset Management Organizer?
Snipet heißt das.
Sleeping Chris ist auch wieder am Start.
Sieben Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Guck mal schnell, ob ich noch was vergessen hab.
Neil C.O. hat subscribt.
Krofax auch, danke schön, Leute.
Massive Sub, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ich geh jetzt mal in den Stundenstream.
Morgen früh, wie immer, wie gehabt.
Aufwachstream, Sonntag.
Nee.
Das, was ich als...
Nicht Snipet, Snipe It.
Das da.
Mit diesem Piercing-Typ als Logo.
Aber das ist total Aufwach-Size
für ein bisschen kleine Hardware-Verwaltung.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich gefunden hab,
was mir von der Bedienung gefallen hat.
Moment, wie spricht man das jetzt richtig aus?
Ich kann das nicht, danke für den Prime-Sub.
Excellent IQ increase für den Chat wieder.
Ist schon morgen oder übermorgen.
Es ist noch heute.
Was hast du heute geschoppt?
Ehrlich gesagt, ziemlich wenig.
Es ist immer heute.
Ja, bis morgen ist heute.
Das ist genauso, wie dass nachts kälter ist als draußen.
Ja, dann ist aber morgen.
Aus heutiger Sicht.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt auf.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns.
Bis morgen früh, machts gut.
Tschüss, tschüss.